Voted the best podcast of all time. I had a laugh riot. Smartless brings all the laughs when three friends, Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes, and Will Arnett, get together and just chop it up and spit it out. It's smartless and it's, wait, am I not doing an ad for the, no? It's just a, it's a cold open. Okay. You're listening to smartless. Smart. Less.
被投票评选为有史以来最棒的播客。我当时笑得前仰后合。当三位好友杰森·贝特曼、肖恩·海斯和威尔·阿奈特聚在一起，随性畅聊、妙语连珠时，“聪明少一点”总能带来无尽的笑声。这就是“聪明少一点”，而且，等等，我这不是在给……没有吗？这只是一个，这是一个开场白。好吧。你正在收听的是“聪明少一点”。聪明。少一点。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure.
聪明。少一点。聪明。少一点。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。
I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure.
我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。
I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I'm not sure. I don't like anything. You don't like anything. Third, Will was third today. No, I was, that's not true. Technically second.
我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我不确定。我什么都不喜欢。你什么都不喜欢。第三，威尔今天排第三。不，我……那不是真的。严格来说是第二。
I was third. Practically second, but technically third because Sean was here earlier. You know what, you know what? I thought that I had more time and I went and I actually, I went to the same guy that Sean did who helped him with his carpal tunnel, Tarek, and he, so I was standing on a rack.
我排第三。实际上是第二，但严格来说是第三，因为肖恩早些时候就到了。你知道吗，你知道吗？我以为我还有更多时间，然后我去了，事实上，我去找了肖恩看腕管综合征的那位按摩师塔里克，他，所以我当时站在一个架子上。
Don't drop Tarek's name in hopes of getting a break on your medical bill from him, okay? That was pathetic. Jason, have you ever gone to him? Let's have the last name too. Go ahead. Jason, have you been to him? Yes, I have.
别把塔里克的名号搬出来，指望能从他那儿减免你的医疗费，好吗？那太可悲了。杰森，你去找过他吗？把姓也说出来。说吧。杰森，你找过他吗？是的，我找过。
Yes, I have. Oh, you have now. He's incredible. Oh, yeah. Oh, really? So why don't you want to? Well, yeah, I had a bad back at some point. Tarek Godra.
是的，我找过。哦，你现在也找了。他太厉害了。哦，真的吗？哦，真的吗？那你为什么不想去？好吧，对，我曾经背疼过。塔里克·戈德拉。
Still do, but- Tarek Godra, he helped to lean. And he- So he's great, And here comes your discount. So I was standing on a, the reason I was late, I was standing on a racquetball. Cause as you know, I have a bad, I had to bail out.
现在还有，不过——塔里克·戈德拉，他帮我纠正了体态。而且他——所以他很棒，接着你的折扣就要来了。所以我当时站在一个，我迟到的原因，我当时站在一个壁球上。因为如你所知，我有个不好的，我得放弃了。
Toe? From my hamstring last week. I had to bail out of golf memory. You and I were with Charlie and Robin. And it got so bad. And he said that there was like basically like buildup on my hamstring around my sciatic nerve. Fuck man, I couldn't even sit down.
脚趾？上周我的腿筋受伤了。我不得不退出高尔夫球局。我和查理还有罗宾在一起。情况变得很糟糕。他说基本上是我的腿筋在坐骨神经周围有劳损。操，我连坐都坐不下。
Is it better now? Yeah, so how's it going? Much better, he's helped it out a lot. Yeah, so what do you gotta do now to maintain it? He made you stand on a racquetball, that fixed it? Yeah, that was part of it. No, it was, you know, my posture was terrible. You know, pillow under your knees when you sleep.
现在好点了吗？对，所以情况怎么样？好多了，他帮我缓解了很多。对，那你现在得做什么来维持呢？他让你站在壁球上，这就治好了？对，那是其中的一部分。不，你知道的，我的姿势太糟糕了。你知道的，睡觉时膝盖下垫个枕头。
How you sit, all this kind of stuff. Anything about eating cereal for dinner? He said, he said double down. Oh, did he? He said double down on that. And instead of milk, ice cream, like a real soft, soft, soft serve ice cream and cereal. Sean just got a boner.
你怎么坐的，诸如此类的事情。有关于晚饭吃麦片的吗？他说，他说加倍。哦，是吗？他说那个要加倍。而且不加牛奶，加冰淇淋，就像那种真正的软冰淇淋加麦片。肖恩听了都要硬了。
Sean, can I ask you a question? So earlier, earlier this morning, before I record here, just, just half hour ago, I'm on a business call, right, because it's a work day. Oh, we're up with a business call. Yeah, a business call. And so I couldn't take the incoming phone call
肖恩，我能问你个问题吗？所以今天早些时候，在我们录音之前，就在半小时前，我正在开一个商务电话，对吧，因为今天是工作日。哦，我们在打商务电话。对，一个商务电话。所以接不了打进来的电话。
from Mr. Arnett, right? Yeah, okay. Just let it go to voicemail. Hang up the business call, check my voicemail. There's no message. Just a record that he's called. Is that what he does with you? Like some, that just won't leave a message, you know?
来自阿奈特先生，对吧？对，好吧。就让它转到语音信箱。挂断商务电话，查看我的语音信箱。没有留言。只有一条他打过电话的记录。他平时也是这样对你的吗？就像那种，就是不肯留个留言，你知道吗？
Because like he's trying to hide the fact that he tried to call and then I didn't pick up. And so he's like too embarrassed to leave a message. No, but do you leave a message? I never leave a message either. Of course I leave a message. Or at least I'll text afterwards and say, hey, tried you. Yeah, well, I'll do that sometimes,
因为就像他在极力掩盖他打过电话而我没接的事实。然后他觉得留言太尴尬了。不对，那你留留言吗？我也从来不留留言。我当然留留言。或者至少我事后会发个短信说，嘿，找过你。对，有时候我会这么做，
but the call is the message. No, it's not enough that there's just a recent call from you. That doesn't qualify. You got to leave me a message if you want to call back. Oh, God. Honestly, no offense to Chris Berman at ESPN, but I think your new nickname might be Boomer. So listen, Boomer, here's the deal. I will say this.
但打个电话本身就是留言。不对，只有你最近的通话记录可不够。那可算不上。你想让我回电话就得给我留个说。哦，天哪。老实说，无意冒犯ESPN的克里斯·伯曼，但我觉得你的新绰号可能是“大嘴”布omer。听着，布omer，情况是这样的。我要这么说：
What we do now is we don't leave messages because there's a record that I called, and so you can decide whether or not. That's your message. That's the message. So that's official? Or were you just trying to hide the fact that you're stalking me like some kind of wounded, wounded ex-boyfriend of mine? Hey, by the way, do you think I wanted to talk to you?
我们现在做的是不留留言，因为有我打过电话的记录，所以你可以决定要不要。这就是你的留言。这就是留言。所以这是官方规定？还是你只是想掩盖你像个受伤的、受伤的前男友一样跟踪我的事实？嘿，顺便说一句，你觉得我想跟你说话吗？
I had to ask you something. Well, is it, let's have a nap. Look at this attitude, do you think I want to deal with this? Right, well, is it, text it. It's like imagine a smile. No, because it's easier. To Jason's credit, yeah.
我得问你点事。好吧，那就，睡个觉吧。看看这态度，你觉得我想应付这个？好吧，那，发短信吧。这就好比想象一个微笑。不，因为这样更简单。有一说一，杰森。
Jason, to your credit, I will always text you, hey, do you got a second? Or you, hey, I want to chat with you. Right, exactly. And you call me right away. You're just doing how I days will. You call me almost. Well, I was just trying, you know what?
杰森，有一说一，我总是会给你发短信，嘿，你有空吗？或者你，嘿，我想跟你聊聊。对，没错。然后你就马上回电话。你只是在学我的日子，威尔。你几乎马上就给我回电话。好吧，我只是想，你知道吗？
You know what? I was just trying to get, I was just trying to make it easy and streamline it. And I was trying to cold call you. Yeah, because we have a relationship that was established on calling years ago. When did we decide that we were gonna text first? I didn't get that text.
你知道吗？我只是想搞定，我只是想让事情变得简单、高效。我是想给你打个冷电。对，因为我们建立关系的年代，大家都是直接打电话的。我们是什么时候决定要先发短信的？我可没收到那个短信。
Now that I got you all warmed up, and you're up in the first round, let's go out there and meet our fighter. Fucking, who we got, Arnett? By the way, our buddy Bradley got seven Oscar nominations for most of his films. Wait, he did? He should have got director Goddammit.
现在我把你热身好了，你准备好打第一轮了，让我们出去见见我们的选手。他妈的，我们有谁，阿奈特？顺便说一句，我们的好哥们布拉德利的大部分电影都获得了七项奥斯卡提名。等一下，他拿了？他本该拿到导演奖的，操。
That's the best directed film of the last decade. I agree. I agree. It's fucking, it's unbelievable. Rice that movie. Listener, there is no better film this year than my show. Full stop. Full stop.
那是过去十年里拍得最好的电影。我同意。我同意。这他妈的，太不可思议了。那部电影太棒了。听众们，今年没有比我的节目更好的电影了。句号。句号。
If you, to do what he did with that film is so incredible. An impossible target. It's so different. Nobody's doing anything like that. Yeah, when I first saw it, I was blown away. It's a stunning piece of work. And I hope he takes solace in the fact
如果你，他对那部电影所做的处理实在是太不可思议了。一个不可能达到的目标。太与众不同了。没有人做出过类似的东西。对，我第一次看的时候，惊呆了。这是一部惊艳的作品。我希望他能感到一丝安慰，
that the Academy will probably look at this and Star is Born as, okay, he did it twice really, really well. So this next one, we're gonna twice really, really well. So this next one, we're going to give him at least a nomination if not the statue. It'd be great if they did it for the next one. Oh yeah, exactly, Willie. So that would be great.
因为学院可能会把这部电影和《一个明星的诞生》看作是：好吧，他两次都拍得非常非常棒。所以接下来这部，我们打算拍得两次都非常非常棒。所以接下来这部，我们要给他至少一个提名，如果不是小金人奖的话。如果他们为下一部颁奖那就太好了。哦，对，没错，威利。那太棒了。
That would be nice. Willie's got one coming up with, Bradley. So speaking of the Academy Awards, our fellow seems to got himself an Academy Award nomination. Today? Yeah, not today, but he has had Academy... I looked at his... He's one of those guys who's got his own award nomination page on Wikipedia because there's so many that they can't even fit in his regular page. I'm getting nervous.
那挺好的。威利有一部要和布拉德利合作的新片。说到奥斯卡奖，我们的这位朋友自己也获得了奥斯卡提名。今天？对，不是今天，但他确实拿过奥斯卡……我看了他的……他是那种在维基百科上有自己专属的奖项提名页面的人，因为奖项太多了，以至于连他的主页都装不下了。我开始紧张了。
Same goes with his filmography. It's got its own fucking page, which most of the times it would bum you out, but with this guy, it's okay. Cause he's one of the good dudes. And he has done stuff, I mean, you're gonna remember a lot of this stuff. Johnny Betts from Private Eye, Taylor Rolater from 21 Jump Street. You might know him as Glenn from Finish Line.
他的电影也是如此。它有它自己的专属页面，大多数时候这会让你觉得沮丧，但对这家伙来说，这没问题。因为他是个好人。他拍过很多作品，我的意思是，你会记得其中的很多。私人侦探里的约翰尼·贝茨，《龙虎少年队》里的泰勒·罗莱特。你可能知道他是《终点线》里的格伦。
You might know him as Jack Passion from Mwonekka Road. Probably, probably not, but you might know him more as Gurney Halleck from Dune, or Thanos from Avengers Endgame, or Dan White for which he was nominated for an Academy Award for 2008's Milk. Guys, it's the unbelievably talented, the explosion that is my favorite JB, Josh Brolin.
你可能知道他是《慕尼黑之路》里的杰克·帕森。可能，可能不会，但你更有可能知道他是《沙丘》里的格尼·哈雷科，或者是《复仇者联盟4：终局之战》里的灭霸，或者是丹·怀特，他曾凭此获得2008年电影《米尔克》的奥斯卡提名。伙计们，他就是才华横溢、犹如炸弹般存在的我最爱的JB，乔什·布洛林。
Oh, Josh. Oh yeah. Oh, Josh. It was just talking about you this morning. Dude, when you started that resume, I go, what the fuck did? The stuff you tried to bury. What is he doing?
哦，乔什。哦，对。哦，乔什。今天早上还在谈论你呢。伙计，当你开始念那份简历时，我在想，这他妈的都是些什么？那些你想掩埋的东西。他在干嘛？
Yeah. Dude, it's all there. Bro, I've come to all the things that you've never seen and don't remember. Welcome our guest. No, I mean, if he just said Goonies, I would have guessed it in two seconds. Well, fuck, I didn't want to say Goonies
是的。伙计，全都在那儿。兄弟，我列出了所有你从未看过也不记得的东西。欢迎我们的嘉宾。不，我的意思是，如果他只说《七宝奇谋》，我两秒钟就能猜出来。好吧，操，我不想说《七宝奇谋》。
because I was trying to go old first. And so if I said Goonies, fucking Sean would have gone, ee, it's time, bro! Josh, does Goonies follow you around like Teen Wolf 2 follows me around? Yeah, but how proud of Teen Wolf for you. Right? Honestly.
因为我一开始想从老电影说起。所以如果我说了《七宝奇谋》，肖恩这混蛋就会说，哦，时间到了，兄弟！乔什，《七宝奇谋》就像《少狼2》追踪我一样一直缠着你吗？对，但你对《少狼》有多骄傲啊。对吧？老实说。
But no, but thank God, both of those... There was a point with Goonies where it was like, please God, give me another movie, any movie that anybody will see. But Goonies was a great film. Teen Wolf 2 had its challenges. It wasn't for trying. But thank God it has turned into just kitsch in our resume, right? But it's not just Teen Wolf two, it's Teen Wolf also.
但是不，谢天谢地，这两部……拍《七宝奇谋》的时候曾有过这样一个阶段，那就是，求求上帝，再给我拍一部电影吧，任何一部会有人看的电影都行。但《七宝奇谋》是一部伟大的电影。《少狼2》有它的挑战。不是没努力过。但谢天谢地，它在我们的简历里已经变成了通俗流行文化，对吧？但不仅仅是《少狼2》，还有《少狼》。
I just want to make the right guess. Yeah, T double L, okay? This is not a sequel, right? I wouldn't dare. I don't know, Josh. Are they gonna do another one? Do you get that? Yeah, Teen Wolf three and three D.
我只是想猜对。对，T双L，对吧？这不是续集，对吧？我才不敢。我不知道，乔什。他们还要拍一部吗？你有这种感觉吗？对，《少狼3》和3D版。
It's in deep development right now. Three and three D. Who's better than Josh Brolin? Look at this. I am so psyched to settle in with JB. I am so psyched you're here, dude. So nice to meet you. Let's start with what you guys met on the set of what was that?
目前正在深度开发中。3和3D。谁比乔什·布洛林更好？瞧瞧这个。我太高兴能和JB坐在一起了。很高兴你能来，伙计。很高兴认识你。让我们从你们在哪部电影的片场相遇开始吧？
What was it? Well, we met before a little bit, but we both, I didn't want to bring up the Razzie-nominated Jonah Hex. Wow. Did it get a Razzie? Why don't you tell the story, if you're willing to tell the story, tell the story that you've told me
是什么来着？嗯，我们之前见过一点，但我们俩，我不想提起那个获得金酸莓奖提名的《西部英雄约拿·海克斯》。哇。它得金酸莓奖了吗？如果你愿意讲这个故事的话，为什么不讲讲这个故事呢，你讲给我听过。
when you over at my house one day, you told me that you were walking by my trailer and what did you see? Do you remember this? It was the end of a long day. We were shooting this scene where we came into, we were on horseback. Do you remember that, Josh in that park
有一天你在我家里，你告诉我你路过我的房车时看到了什么？你还记得吗？那是一个漫长一天的结束。我们正在拍那个场景，我们骑着马进到，我们在骑马。你还记得吗，乔什，在那个公园里。
and they set up the old town? And John Gallagher and I came in leading, I did not know how to ride a horse. They taught me, wrote in the town. Anyway, so it was like a dusty day. We'd been on horseback all day and I walked by and Josh had this incredible makeup for Jonah Hex that took hours to put on.
他们搭好了老城镇？然后约翰·加拉格尔和我带头进去了，我当时根本不会骑马。他们教我，骑着马进了镇子。总之，那是个尘土飞扬的日子。我们骑了一整天马，我路过时，乔什化着那副令人难以置信的约拿·海克斯妆，花了几个小时才画好。
He could barely move, he could speak out of one side of his mouth. The other one had this prosthetic on that took forever. And then had a hole in the prosthetic. So I couldn't. And a hole in the prosthetic. So I walked by his trailer and it's like 6 p.m. We've been shooting 12 hours as hot as fucking New Orleans,
他几乎动弹不得，只能从嘴的一侧说话。另一侧戴着那个花了半天时间才弄好的假体。而且假体上有一个洞。所以我不能。假体上还有一个洞。所以我路过他的房车时，大约是下午6点。我们已经拍了12个小时，热得像新奥尔良该死的天气，
like a thousand degrees. And Josh is sitting on the steps of his trailer with a cigarette sticking out of the hole of his presser. And I had to put a finger over the hole in order to be able to inhale the cigarette. And I had, what else could I have? And he was holding a bottle of whiskey. Makers mark.
就像有一千度一样。乔什正坐在他房车的台阶上，嘴里叼着一根从他假体上的洞里戳出来的香烟。我不得不把一根手指按在那个洞上才能把烟吸进去。我还有什么，我还能有什么？他手里还拿着一瓶威士忌。美格。
He was holding a bottle of Makers mark in his fucking hand drinking. At 11 o'clock in the morning. It sounded like he had a triple banger too, or a double banger. It was a little later than that, but it was. And the fact that I blame Jonah Hex on anybody else is a fucking joke
他他妈手里拿着一瓶美格威士忌在喝。早上11点。听起来他当时还喝了三勒浆还是两勒浆来着。那是稍微晚一点的时候，不过确实是。而我把约拿·海克斯的失败归咎于别人，简直是个天大的笑话。
I Gotta see that movie man. Oh you have to look handsome the trailer looked great. It looked like a cowboy I will tell you that much. I was like this motherfucker came to fucking play Can I tell you a quick story about that actually? Fuckin' play. Can I tell you a quick story about that, actually? So we went to the premiere and we're looking and the studio kind of took over that movie and they made it even worse than it already was.
我得去看看那部电影，伙计。哦，你得看看，预告片看起来挺帅的。看起来像个牛仔，我跟你说。我当时想，这王八蛋是来动真格的。我能跟你们讲个关于这事的简短故事吗？动真格的。我能跟你们讲个关于这事的简短故事吗？所以我们去参加首映式，我们在看，电影公司有点接管了那部电影，他们把它改得比原来更糟了。
And it wasn't that bad. It really wasn't that bad. But we left early, as one does, at their own premiere. And there was a guy in a wheelchair that left just before me that didn't see that I left behind him when my wife and I left the door and he thought he was by himself and he was wheeling himself out
其实也没那么糟。真的没那么糟。但我们提前离场了，就像人们在自己的首映式上做的那样。有一个坐轮椅的家伙比我早离开一点，他没看见我跟在我妻子身后离开门，他以为周围只有他一个人，他自己推着轮椅出来，
and he said 86 minutes of a waste of fucking life. Ah! Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha The worst review I've ever gotten. I'd rather lose the other leg than see that shit again. Yeah, exactly, exactly. It's really funny. Sorry to interrupt. Well, I don't wanna. Yeah, go ahead, Charlie. I don't wanna rant on your parade,
然后他说：“这他妈是浪费了86分钟生命。”啊！哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈.我这辈子听过最烂的评价。我宁愿失去另一条腿也不想再看那破玩意儿了。对，没错，没错。太搞笑了。抱歉打断一下。好吧，我不想。行，说吧，查理。我不想破坏你的兴致，
but just let me know if it's now or 40 minutes I can talk about Dune, because I have 800,000 questions. Okay, you can talk about Dune anytime you want. You can start now. If you want, I was gonna start a little further back than his most recent project to be seeing on. Josh, so I wanted to talk, man, it's so great to have you.
但只要告诉我，是现在还是40分钟后我可以聊聊《沙丘》，因为我有80万个问题。好吧，你想什么时候聊《沙丘》都行。现在就可以开始。如果你想的话，我打算从比他最近的作品稍早一点的时候开始说起。乔什，所以我想聊聊，伙计，很高兴你能来。
You're one of the all-time great dudes. And I really mean that just outside of even the shit that we do, you're a great dude. And you started, obviously, your dad was in the business, your mom was in the business. And so you started with that, and yet you kind of took you a minute. You didn't start, you weren't like a child actor
你是史上最棒的家伙之一。我是说真的，抛开我们干的那些破事不谈，你是个绝佳的家伙。你的起点，很显然，你爸爸在这个圈子里，你妈妈在这个圈子里。所以你是从那开始的，但你花了一点时间。你并不是那种童星，
in the sense that, like when you were first young, you weren't really doing it. Am I right about that? You were kind of outside of LA, and then you kind of came back to it? Is that sort of cool? Yeah, I wasn't, I was born in LA. I was born in Santa Monica,
那种意思就是，当你还小的时候，你其实并没有真正从事这个。我没说错吧？你算是离开过洛杉矶，然后又回来的？是这样吗？对，我不是，我出生在洛杉矶。我出生在圣莫尼卡，
which goes back five generations, I believe. Wow. St. John's. St. John's. Where my father was born and my grandfather was born. Holy shit. And my kid, my kid, two of my kids were born in St. John's. Wow. So, no, I was raised, we left the valley.
那里的历史可以追溯到五代之前，我相信。哇。圣约翰医院。圣约翰。我父亲在那里出生，我爷爷也在那里出生。操。而且我的孩子，我的孩子，我的两个孩子都是在圣约翰出生的。哇。所以，不，我是被抚养长大的，我们离开的山谷。
I believe it was Chatsworth when I was five and we went to Passerobels. My mom was in the business as an assistant casting director, but that was it. Primarily she ran a wildlife way station and took wild animals away from people who had illegally taken them out of the wild and had them jailed.
我记得我五岁时住在查茨沃斯，然后我们搬到了帕索罗布斯。我妈妈在这个圈子里当过助理选角导演，但也就这样了。主要是她经营着一个野生动物救助站，把人们从野外非法捕获并关起来的野生动物解救出来。
My mother was a five foot three Texan blonde tornado. I smell a real compelling one hour episodic. Right? Yeah. And by the way, we just wrote a book that's gonna be out in November 19th that I didn't really know what the book was and it's kind of an unconventional memoir
我母亲是一个身高五英尺三英寸的德州金发龙卷风。我嗅到了一个极具吸引力的一小时连续剧题材。对吧？对。顺便说一句，我们刚刚写了一本书，将于11月19日出版，我当时其实并不知道这本书是什么，它有点像一本非传统的回忆录，
but it's very mother heavy. Fucking eight. Where you wrote? What's the name of it? Plug It. It's not, I can't plug it. Because I'm not allowed to, but yeah. But it is coming out in November, Harper Collins. But yeah, man, so my dad was an actor.
但里面有很多关于母亲的内容。他妈的八。你写的？书名叫什么？插入。不是，我不能宣传。因为我不被允许，但是对。但它确实要在11月出版了，哈珀柯林斯出版社。但是，伙计，我爸爸是个演员。
He stayed in LA most of the time. He went back and forth and drove the four hours to Paso Robles. So I had no real, I mean, I think I went on his sets. I think I went on Marcus Welby once and I think I went on Amityville horror once. And I was up on the catwalk at 11 years old where he walked in. And I didn't know, I didn't know the process. We never talked about it.
他大部分时间都待在洛杉矶。他两头跑，开四个小时的车去帕索罗布斯。所以我没有什么真正的，我的意思是，我想我去过他的片场。我想我去过一次《马库斯·韦尔比》的片场，我想我去过一次《鬼哭神嚎》的片场。我11岁时就站在高处走道上，他走了进来。而且我不知道，我根本不知道拍戏的流程。我们从来没谈过这个。
So Tracy, the catwalk is the permanent walkways way up at the top of the soundstage, usually like 30 feet above the ground. Way up at the top, so I'm looking down and I'm watching my dad, you hear action, which I don't even know what that is, and he comes in through the door with an ax and goes to another door. That's crazy.
所以，崔西，高处走道是摄影棚顶部那些永久性的通道，通常离地面大约30英尺高。高高在上，所以我向下看，看着我爸爸，你听到“开拍”，我甚至不知道那是什么，他拿着一把斧头穿过一门，走向另一扇门。这太疯狂了。
Where somebody's doing off camera to help him out, but I don't know that. No, no! And he's axing the door. And I'm like, and it reminded me of this story that I heard once of Laura Dern saying the first time she ever saw her dad on film was his head rolling down a flight of stairs.
有人在镜头外帮他忙，但我不知道。不，不！他在砍门。然后我想，这让我想起我曾听过的一个故事，劳拉·邓恩说她第一次在电影里看到她爸爸时，他的头正顺着一楼梯往下滚。
Oh my God. But I remember that there was no, there was never anything, I don't have that story of like, oh my God, when I was four, I was doing little plays I made up on my head in front of my family and I just knew at five, this is, yeah, it was none of that. So I had no interest in the acting thing and then ultimately just to jump forward,
天哪。但我记得没有什么，从来没有什么，我没有那种故事，比如，天哪，当我四岁的时候，我在家人面前表演我自己编的小短剧，我五岁时就知道，是的，根本没有那回事。所以我对演戏毫无兴趣，然后最终，快进一下，
I took, I was kind of flunking out of school once we moved to Santa Barbara and I did an improv class. And I didn't even know what it was. It was like, you can do underwater basket weaving or improv. And I was like, I guess I'll do the improv. But really had like a bad taste about the acting thing because my dad made money and then spent that money. And then we had no money. And then we had money. And then we had no money. And I said, what the fuck would anybody wanna do that? So ultimately I took that class
我们搬到圣巴巴拉后，我差点从学校辍学，我去上了一个即兴表演班。我甚至不知道那是什么。就像，你可以选水下编篮子或者即兴表演。我就想，我想我还是选即兴表演吧。但其实我对演戏有种不好的印象，因为我爸爸赚了钱，然后就把钱花光。然后我们没钱。然后我们又有钱。然后我们又没钱。我说，谁他妈会想干那种事？所以最终我上了那门课，
and I remember I was the first person asked to get up and she said, so what this is is you create a character and any character you want, any character that comes to mind and from the house, the students, we're gonna ask you questions and you answer as that character. And I had created some kind of middle-aged New Yorker and I don't even know how I knew that at that point. Like an overweight middle-aged balding New Yorker.
我记得我是第一个被叫起来的人，她说，所以这个的意思是，你创造一个角色，任何你想要的角色，任何你能想到的角色，然后来自台下的学生们，我们要问你问题，你以那个角色的身份来回答。我当时创造了一个有点中年的纽约人，我甚至不知道那时候我是怎么知道这一点的。就像一个发福的中年谢顶纽约人。
And- How old were you? I think I was at that point maybe 15, 14, 15. And then when I was answered, then there was laughter, right? And that was it. Like that was so- You loved that. Yeah, so it had nothing to do with what I was answered, then there was laughter, right? And that was it. Like that was so, yeah. So it had nothing to do with what I was surrounded by. If anything, I was never gonna be an actor.
而且——你当时多大？我想我当时大概15岁，14、15岁。然后当我回答时，台下传来了笑声，对吧？就是这样。就像那个——你很喜欢那种感觉。对，所以这跟我周围的环境没有任何关系。如果要说的话，我压根就没打算当演员。
And it was that kind of drug induced, the drug of the laughter. Yeah, yeah, for sure. Well that or the attention or the, you can see that you're good at something. Like I wonder, because I think for any kid, yeah, but any kid right at that age, if you put something in front of them
那是一种由笑声带来的、类似毒品般的体验。对，对，肯定的。要么是那样，要么是关注度，或者是你能看出你擅长某事。我在想，因为我觉得对于任何孩子来说，对，但任何处于那个年龄的孩子，如果你把某种东西摆在他们面前，
that they don't suck at and they get some sort of, you know, charming sort of social status, I mean, I'm seeing it with my kids now, Willie, I'm sure you are too, you know, it's like right about this age, then we're between 12 and 17, like you're trying to like, where do I fit in? What's my lane?
他们并不逊色，并且能从中获得某种，你知道的，迷人的社会地位，我的意思是，我现在从我的孩子们身上看到了这一点，威利，我确信你也是，你知道的，就在这个年龄段，我们在12岁到17岁之间，就像你在努力寻找：我在哪里能合群？我的赛道是什么？
What's my group? What am I good at? What should I never do again? And for me, it was the same thing, Josh. It was sort of this, this acting like, well, that's where I got my attention. That's where guys thought I was cool and girls wanted to hang out with me. And it could have been anything else. I did this play. I did 12th night, Shakespeare's 12th night in high school. I didn't understand a word I was saying. And until there was an audience, there's one line that says, I'll make one too.
我的圈子是什么？我擅长什么？我再也不应该做什么？对我和来说，也是一样，乔什。就是这种，这种表演，好吧，这就是我获得关注的地方。这就是男生觉得我很酷、女生想跟我混在一起的地方。而且也可以是别的任何东西。我演过一出戏。我在高中演过《第十二夜》，莎士比亚的《第十二夜》。我一个字也没听懂。直到有了观众，里面有一句台词是：“我也要做一个。”
And that's the end of the scene. And it got a massive laugh. 16, 17 years old, no idea why anybody laughed. And I was like, oh, that's who that character is. And that's why people are laughing. And then it clicked. So yeah, it's interesting, Jason, what you just said. It's like, until you get that drug,
那是场景的结尾。那句台词引来了一阵巨大的笑声。16、17岁，根本不知道大家在笑什么。我就想，哦，原来那个角色是这样的。这就是大家在笑的原因。然后我开窍了。所以，是的，这很有意思，杰森，你刚才说的。就像，直到你尝到那种禁果，
you just don't know what it is. I was just thinking about like, how strange you do something and then people give you a lot of positive feedback and why would you wanna do that? Right, you gotta be careful what you put in front of your kid at that age, cause that's what they're gonna end up doing. But Josh, when you did, like, Amityville horror was damaging to me.
你根本不知道那是什么感觉。我刚才在想，你做了一件很奇怪的事，然后人们给了你很多积极的反馈，你为什么会想停下来？对，你得小心你在那个年龄段摆在孩子面前的东西，因为那正是他们最后会去从事的行业。但是乔什，当你演的时候，比如《鬼哭神嚎》对我来说有心理阴影。
Like, I saw that as a kid. And I was like, it was like, it was one of the scariest things I've ever seen. You growing up on that set, did you, could you then go back and watch the movie having experienced seeing filming it and get immersed into it? Or did you see the, how the sausage was made?
就像，我小时候看过。然后我觉得，那是我看过的最吓人的东西之一。你在那个片场长大，你当时能回去重新看那部电影，带着拍摄的经历并全身心投入其中吗？还是说你看透了香肠是怎么做出来的？
But not having grown up on the set, only having seen that scene. But even that, even that. No, I had no interest, man. I'm telling you, I had no interest and it wasn't until very irresponsibly, my dad took me to the theater, the mission theater, to see apocalypse now.
但我并不是在片场长大的，只看过那个场景。即便如此，即便如此。不，我一点兴趣也没有，伙计。我告诉你，我一点兴趣也没有，直到我父亲很不负责任地带我去任务剧院看《现代启示录》。
Sure, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Which, I mean, that was one of those, that's one of those immersive things where you're like What the fuck are they doing? How old were you when you saw that? I was 11 Yeah, that's enough. I was two and a half Sorry, sorry. Yeah, you were Hollywood two and a half fucking seeing that 11 like I don't think I saw Well, what about Jaws? I mean, Jaws was out in, what, 7-5?
当然，是的。对，对。那真的是那种，那种让你身临其境的体验，你会想：这群人在干什么？你看的时候多大？我11岁。对，那够大了。我当时两岁半。抱歉，抱歉。对，你个好莱坞小子两岁半他妈的就看那个了。11岁时看，我觉得我没看过——那《大白鲨》呢？我的意思是，《大白鲨》是什么时候上映的，75年？
Jaws? I saw Jaws in the theater. I was six. I was six at 7-5, and that's why. Or Rocky, do you remember seeing Rocky? Oh, yes. And like, the fact that like he doesn't win the fight, but it's a great, big, happy ending,
《大白鲨》？我在电影院看的《大白鲨》。我当时六岁。75年我六岁，这就是为什么。或者《洛基》，你还记得看《洛基》吗？哦，是的。而且像他并没有赢得比赛，但这是一个伟大的、皆大欢喜的结局，
I was just like, how do you pull that magic trick off? Yeah, exactly. We'll be right back. Smartlist gets support from ZipRecruiter. Tis the month of St. Patty's Day. And here's a random related fact. Did you know that the odds of finding a lucky four-leaf clover are one in 10,000?
我当时就在想，你怎么能变出那种魔术呢？对，没错。我们马上回来。“聪明少一点”节目得到了ZipRecruiter的大力支持。正值圣帕特里克节月。这里有一个与之相关的随机事实。你知道找到一颗幸运四叶草的几率是一万分之一吗？
I'd say that's pretty difficult. Fortunately, if you're a business owner or hiring manager, you don't need luck to find top talent for your team. You need ZipRecruiter. And right now, you can try it for free at ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Zip Recruiter's powerful matching technology shows you qualified matches right after you post your job. Once you review your list of qualified candidates, you can easily invite them to apply. Aren't you just a wee bit curious to see how Zip Recruiter can help you? Well, today's your lucky day because you can try ZipRecruiter for free!
我觉得这相当困难。幸运的是，如果你是一位企业主或招聘经理，你不需要运气来为你的团队寻找顶尖人才。你需要ZipRecruiter。现在，你可以免费试用，网址是ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter强大的匹配技术会在你发布职位后立即为你展示合格的匹配人选。一旦你审查了合格候选人名单，你就可以轻松邀请他们申请。难道你不好奇ZipRecruiter是如何帮助你的吗？今天真是你的幸运日，因为你可以免费试用ZipRecruiter！
Just go to ZipRecruiter.com slash SmartLess. In fact, four out of five employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate within the first day. Once again, just go to this exclusive web address to try ZipRecruiter for free. That's ZipRecruiter.com slash SmartLess. ZipRecruiter, the smartest way to hire. This episode of SmartLess is brought to you in part by Skinny Pop Popcorn. Looking for some excitement?
只需访问ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。事实上，在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的雇主中，有五分之四在第一天内就能找到优质候选人。再次强调，只需访问这个专属网址即可免费试用ZipRecruiter。网址是ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。本期“聪明少一点”节目部分由Skinny Pop爆米花赞助播出。寻找一些刺激？
Check out Skinny Pop's new cheddar jalapeno popcorn. Made with real cheddar cheese and a pop of jalapeno, this new flavor is sure to spice up your daily snacking routine. For me, guess what I do? When I have a sandwich, whether it's a tuna sandwich or a peanut butter sandwich or whatever, instead of chips, sometimes I'll use Skinny Pop and I'll use that as my side. And guess what? It's delicious.
来看看Skinny Pop全新的切达墨西哥辣椒味爆米花吧。这款新口味采用真正的切达干酪和少许墨西哥辣椒制成，必将为你的日常零食时间增添无限风味。对我来说，你猜我怎么做？当我吃三明治时，无论是金枪鱼三明治还是花生酱三明治或其他什么，我不吃薯片，有时我会用Skinny Pop来配餐。你猜怎么着？太好吃了。
It is. It's a deliciously simple combination of popcorn, oil, and salt. Every bite of their perfectly popped original popcorn leaves you wanting more. Skinny Pop is light and tasty and perfect for any occasion, whether you're on the go, saving off boredom, or unwinding after a long day. In addition to the original popcorn, Skinny Pop offers a variety of delicious flavors, ranging from white cheddar to sweet and salty kettle, all perfectly popped endlessly delicious. Shop Skinny Pop now!
确实如此。它是爆米花、油和盐的美味而简单的结合。他们完美爆开的原味爆米花每一口都让人回味无穷。Skinny Pop轻盈美味，完美适合任何场合，无论你是在旅途中、驱赶无聊，还是在漫长的一天后放松身心。除了原味爆米花，Skinny Pop还提供各种美味口味，从白切达干酪到香甜海盐焦糖，应有尽有，完美爆开，无尽美味。立即购买Skinny Pop！
Thanks to Grammarly for their support. You know, I'm always writing emails, I'm actually writing post-its around my house, and I kind of just write, like, whether it's on the computer or handwrite, as fast as I can, and my brain always thinks faster than my hand, so I'm always getting the words wrong.
感谢Grammarly的大力支持。你知道的，我一直在写电子邮件，我其实还在我家里到处贴便签，我基本上就是写，不管是在电脑上还是手写，以最快的速度写，我的大脑总是比我的手转得快，所以我总是把字写错。
But no matter what kind of work you do, how you communicate is key. All those emails, reports, and presentations are equally important to the collaboration needed to get things done, and Grammarly can help. Grammarly makes me feel more confident in my writing, and it makes me more efficient in the fact that I can say so much with the fewest words. And it also just checks for my mistakes because I'm not in school anymore, I don't have a teacher to do it. You know what I mean?
但无论你做什么类型的工作，如何沟通都是关键。所有这些电子邮件、报告和演示文稿对于完成工作所需的协作都同样重要，而Grammarly可以提供帮助。Grammarly让我对自己的写作更有信心，它让我更有效率，因为我可以用最少的字表达最多的意思。它还会帮我检查错误，因为我不再是学生了，没有老师来帮我改了。你知道我的意思吗？
96% of Grammarly users report that Grammarly helps them craft more impactful writing. By understanding your writing and context, Grammarly provides personalized suggestions to help you navigate even the most difficult work conversations. With 14 years of experience and just about every IT certification under the sun, Grammarly is the gold standard of responsible AI. Make a bigger impact at work with Grammarly. Sign up and download for free at grammarly.com slash smartlist. All right, back to the show. So, Josh, so then what happens and you were like, first of all, I don't wanna, it's kind of two questions.
96%的Grammarly用户表示，Grammarly帮助他们创作出更具影响力的作品。通过理解你的写作和语境，Grammarly提供个性化建议，帮助你驾驭即使是最困难的工作对话。凭借14年的经验和几乎所有的IT认证，Grammarly是负责任的人工智能的黄金标准。使用Grammarly在工作中产生更大的影响。在grammarly.com/smartless上注册并免费下载。好了，回到节目中。那么，乔什，接下来发生了什么，你就像是，首先，我不想，这其实是两个问题。
When you were up there, you were kind of, you surfed a lot that played a big part in your life, right? You were a big time surfer, that took a lot of your time. You had a whole gang of pals who you surfed with. And then you kind of, and then you get goonies. And what's that like? How did that come about?
当你还在那儿的时候，你有点，你经常冲浪，那在你的生活中占了很大一部分，对吧？你曾是个资深冲浪手，那占用了你大量的时间。你有一帮一起冲浪的好哥们。然后你，然后你得到了《七宝奇谋》。那是什么感觉？你是怎么得到这个角色的？
Cause that was your first thing really, right? Everything is super morbid. If I, every story, thank God for you guys. Being able to check. Welcome to the party. By the way, morbid podcasts are like the best. They do the best on the charts. Order a man.
因为那真的是你的第一部作品，对吧？每件事都超级病态。如果我，每个故事，感谢你们。能够核实一下。欢迎来到派对。顺便说一句，病态播客就像是最棒的。它们在排行榜上表现最好。点一个男人。
We got Josh Brolin. Oh, what the fuck? Yeah, what the fuck? Um, yeah, what? So I grew up with these guys called themselves, we called ourselves, I'll include myself in that, the Cito rats. And most of those guys, 37 out of probably 50 of us are dead now.
我们请到了乔什·布洛林。哦，搞什么鬼？对，搞什么鬼？呃，什么？所以我跟这群人一起长大，他们自称，我们自称——我也把自己算在内——西托帮。我们这群人里的大多数，在大概50个人里有37人现在已经死了。
And that was the beginning of the punk rock era. That was an amazing time. It was an electric time. It was an electric time. It was a fun time. But I got kicked out of my house at 16. And I went down to, I lived on my dad's couch. Wait, what was your fence? I had the fences my mouth, you know?
那是朋克摇滚时代的开始。那是一个神奇的时代。那是一个充满电力的时代。那是一个充满电力的时代。那是一个有趣的时代。但我16岁时被赶出了家门。我去了，我住在我爸爸的沙发上。等等，你犯了什么事？我满嘴都是刺，你知道吗？
I just grabbed myself in a lot of drawers. Cast me a few schools. Words, yeah, exactly. So, yeah, my mom said, it's time for you to leave. And I left and I stayed with my dad who was living with his girlfriend in this apartment. And this was an attempt to kind of get my shit together. So I made up a resume.
我惹上了不少麻烦。被好几所学校开除了。粗话，对，没错。所以，是的，我妈妈说，你该走了。然后我离开了我住在我爸和他的女朋友租的这套公寓里。这算是试图让我的人生重回正轨。所以我伪造了一份简历，
I started doing martial arts, which one does when you try to get your shit together? Sure. And I was fairly decent at that. And I started competing martial arts, which one does when you try to get your shit together? Sure. And I was fairly decent at that. And I started competing doing that. And at the same time I made up, my dad said, why don't you like try and like work a little bit?
我开始练习武术，当你试图让生活重回正轨时人总会这么做？当然。我在这方面还算凑合。我开始参加武术比赛，当你试图让生活重回正轨时人总会这么做？当然。我在这方面还算凑合。我开始参加武术比赛。与此同时我伪造了一份，我爸说，你为什么不试着稍微工作一下呢？
Why don't you do theater? Why don't you do that? And I was like, oh yeah, I can do that. And I made up a resume. It was 100% made up. And I went from agent to agent trying to get an agent and saying that I was at, like I had done streetcar at the Liberaro International Theater.
你为什么不去演话剧？你为什么不去做那个？我就想，哦，对，我可以做那个。我伪造了一份简历。100%是伪造的。我一个中介接一个中介地跑，试图找个中介，说我在，比如我在利贝拉罗国际剧院演过《欲望号街车》。
There is no Liberaro International Theater. Sure, sure. And at the same time I did see streetcar and I saw East of Eden and those two movies had a major impact. Anyway, somebody, Hillary Shore, took me on, even though she knew the whole resume was bullshit. And she took me on.
根本没有什么利贝拉罗国际剧院。当然，当然。与此同时，我确实看过《欲望号街车》，我也看过《伊甸园之东》，这两部电影产生了重大的影响。总之，有人，希拉里·肖，签下了我，尽管她知道整份简历都是胡扯。她签下了我。
And I probably had back then, when you would do auditions, you would go to three or four auditions in a day. Yeah, yeah. And I think I did around 350 auditions before I met Dick Donner and Steven Spielberg. Wow. I didn't really know who they were, but that was a six audition process before they said.
那时候我大概，你去试镜的时候，一天要去三四次试镜。对，对。我想在我遇到迪克·唐纳和史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格之前，我大概经历了350场试镜。哇。我当时其实不知道他们是谁，那是经历了六轮试镜后他们才最终决定。
Really? With nothing but a fucking Thomas guide and a lot of hope, right? Bunch of headshots, yeah. It's an accident. Yeah. And I wasn't good. I can't say I was good.
真的吗？只凭着一本该死的汤姆逊地图册和满腔希望，对吧？一堆大头照，对。这是一场意外。对。而且我当时演得并不好。我不能说我演得好。
I said, the same goes to today. If you do Dune with a certain director, it's gonna be a certain thing. Somebody who understands what take to use, whatever. And then if you do Dune with a certain director, it's gonna be a certain thing. Somebody who understands what take to use, whatever. And then if you do Dune with Denis Villeneuve, it's gonna, you know, the foundation, the worst it's gonna be is still really good. Well, so actually, talk about that.
我说，今天也是一样。如果你跟某个特定的导演合作《沙丘》，那就会是一种特定的效果。一个懂得用哪个镜头的人，诸如此类。然后如果你跟另一个特定的导演合作《沙丘》，那又会是一种特定的效果。一个懂得用哪个镜头的人，诸如此类。然后如果你跟丹尼斯·维伦纽夫合作《沙丘》，你知道的，基础再差也依然会非常好。好吧，所以实际上，谈谈这个。
And now we're gonna end it Dune, Sean. But I do wanna say, as a sort of entree to that, that's a really interesting point, Josh, that you can go and do something. And part of the reason that people like you choose directors and choose projects are because you say, I wanna be with that person because I believe that I'm in good hands.
我们最后要聊到《沙丘》，肖恩。但我确实想说，作为引子，这是一个非常有趣的点，乔什，你可以去拍一些东西。人们像你这样选择导演和项目的部分原因是因为你说：我想和那个人在一起，因为我相信我遇到了贵人。
I believe that A, that the script's good. I believe that their vision of it executing is good and that the way that they're from start to finish, from casting to shooting to editing to all of that kind of stuff, that they're from start to finish, from casting to shooting to editing to all of that kind of stuff, that they're gonna do something that I believe, that I trust in, right? Like, because you're putting your trust in that process.
我相信A，剧本很好。我相信他们对执行的愿景很好，而且他们从头到尾，从选角到拍摄到剪辑到所有这些乱七八糟的事情，他们从头到尾，从选角到拍摄到剪辑到所有这些乱七八糟的事情，他们做出的东西是我所相信的，是我所信任的，对吧？因为你把信任放在了那个流程中。
Yeah, but I also think, you know, just to kind of preface it, and then more up your alley, Sean, is that, you know, theater, I met a guy named Anthony Zerbe, and Anthony Zerbe was one of the great Shakespearean actors, maybe the lesser known, and he had a poetry thing that he did,
对，但我也觉得，你知道，就当是铺垫一下，然后更符合你的调性，肖恩，你知道的，戏剧，我遇到过一个叫安东尼·泽比的人，安东尼·泽比是伟大的莎士比亚演员之一，可能不太出名，他有一个诗歌朗诵项目，
which I can't think of anything more, I don't know if you remember Cafe Lalo, back in the day on Fairfax, and Steve Baldwin would go and read his poetry, and it was all just super dumb. And I met a guy around that time named Anthony Zerbe. And Anthony Zerbe and Roscoe Lee Brown, the great Roscoe Lee Brown would do
我想不出比这更，我不知道你记不记得费尔法克斯当年的拉洛咖啡馆，史蒂夫·鲍德温会去那里读他的诗，那简直蠢透了。我当时遇到了一个叫安东尼·泽比的人。安东尼·泽比和罗斯科·李·布朗，伟大的罗斯科·李·布朗会表演
an hour and a half of poetry. And I saw it and it fucking blew my mind. The fact that they had such a command over the language and they understood pause, they understood cadence, they understood weight, and all that kind of stuff. So I got together with Anthony, and I started doing theater in Rochester, New York,
一个半小时的诗。我当时看了，整个人震撼得无以复加。他们对语言的掌控力，对停顿、节奏、分量的理解，以及诸如此类的一切。所以我联系了安东尼，开始在纽约罗切斯特演戏剧，
and I did five seasons of theater in Rochester, New York. So when you get that kind of vibe, what you were talking about back from the audience, and when a play is not very good, and yet chemistry is really good with another actor, and then that can kind of send the play in a different place and you see people crying and you see people laughing. You know, again, that's the addiction.
我在纽约罗切斯特演了五季戏剧。所以当你从观众那里得到那种共鸣，就像你刚才说的，当一部剧其实不太好，但你和其他演员之间的化学反应真的很棒，然后那种化学反应就能把整部剧带向一个不同的方向，你看到人们在哭，看到人们在笑。你知道，这又是一种让人上瘾的东西。
You're like, oh, there's response here and there's, you know, there's kind of- I can move you. Yeah. Do you have a favorite of those plays back when you- I did a play that never went anywhere called Pits and Joe and it was a guy with traumatic brain stem injury that had gotten into a motorcycle accident
你会觉得，哦，这里有反馈，而且你知道，有那种——我能打动你。对。在你当年那些戏里，有没有你最喜欢的一部？我演过一部从来没火过的剧叫《Pits and Joe》，讲的是一个遭遇摩托车事故的家伙，患有创伤性脑干损伤，
and was based in truth. And this woman wrote it about her and her brother. And I did one of those things where, back when you wanted to be Daniel Day-Lewis or whoever, and I went into the care center that Joe was at. And I checked in, I met with the head of the care center, I met with like the five heads, the psychology head and all that.
而且是根据真实事件改编的。有个女人写了关于她和她弟弟的故事。我当时就做了那种事，就像当年你想成为丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯或者别的什么大咖一样，我去了乔所在的护理中心。我办理了登记，见了一下护理中心的负责人，见了大约五个负责人，心理学主管之类的。
And I said, I really wanna live in here as one of these people for a couple of weeks. Can you not tell anybody else that I'm actually not, I'm gonna see if I can pull it off. And I remember that like after the second day there was somebody I was smoking or something or trying to smoke or put a cigarette in my mouth. And a nurse came up to me and she said,
然后我说，我真的很想在这里作为这些病人之一生活几个星期。你们能不能别告诉任何人其实我不是病人，我要看看我能不能装得像一点。我记得大约在第二天的时候，我在抽烟还是干嘛，或者正试图抽烟、把烟叼在嘴里。有个护士走过来对我说，
Josh, you can't, you're not a lot. And she was screaming in my ear. And I wanted to say, shut the fuck up. She's like, I'm acting, okay? I'm acting. Ah. She bought a ticket to the opening night, yeah. There was the head of the psychology that there,
乔，你不能这样，你不能……她在我耳边大喊大叫。我当时真想说，给老娘闭嘴。她就像是，我在演戏，好吗？我在演戏。啊。她还买票去看了首演夜，对。当时心理学主管也在，
he hated me and he hated what I was doing. And I was waiting by myself to have my, you know, two cigarettes of the day. And he walked by me and it was just he and I. And he whispered, or he kind of like, you know, two cigarettes of the day. And he walked by me and it was just he and I. And he whispered, or he kind of like, you know, snarky, said as he was walking by, he said, Joe would never do that. Remember, I felt a rage. And it was the rage that I felt.
他恨透了我，也恨透了我做的事。我一个人站在那里，等着抽我（你知道的）一天里仅有的两支烟。他从我身边走过，当时就我和他两个人。他低声说，或者说他有点像，你知道的，一天里仅有的两支烟。他从我身边走过，当时就我和他两个人。他低声说，或者说他有点像，你知道的，用尖酸的语气，边走边说，乔绝不会那样做。记住，我当时感到一股怒火。那种怒火燃起来了。
And then the connection between if Joe feels a rage, he would never be able to get up. So therefore I can't get up. And that was what I needed to go play that. I love that. I love that. I love that. I have you stayed that kind of a researching actor, or have you found that, you know, what you've got, what you've absorbed in your life gives you enough of a toolbox to apply to any character that you're attracted to nowadays? I think both, and I think what I'm going through right now,
然后我就想，如果乔感到愤怒，他是绝对站不起来的。所以因此我也不能站起来。这就是我演好那个角色所需要的状态。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。你一直保持着这种做研究型演员的习惯吗？还是你发现，你的人生经历所吸收的东西，已经为你提供了足够丰富的工具箱，足以应用到你现在接演的任何角色上？我觉得两者都有，而且我觉得我现在正在经历的，
you know, I've been very lucky to be offered a lot of really nice things recently. And I think that the hunger right now is to kind of go back to 2008 or 2000, or go back to that theater experience because I miss having to do or feeling like I have to do the research. Well, I tell you something about the research.
你知道的，我最近很幸运能接到很多非常好的片约。我觉得现在这种饥饿感，就是想回到2008年或者2000年，或者回到那种戏剧体验中去，因为我很怀念那种必须去做、或者觉得自己必须去做研究的感觉。好吧，关于做研究这件事，我跟你讲个事。
It reminded me, Josh, of a story you told me years ago where you, when you did No Country for Old Man, which is just such a spectacular movie. One of my favorites. Oh my God. So, so good, and you're so good at it. And I remember we were talking, maybe it was when we were doing Jonah Hex,
乔什，这让我想起你多年前跟我讲过的一个故事，当时你拍《老无所依》的时候，那真是一部无与伦比的电影。我最喜欢的电影之一。天哪。太棒了，太棒了，你在里面演得真好。我还记得我们在聊天，也许是我们在拍《约拿·海克斯》的时候，
but you were saying there's that scene early on where you're going to, and the motorcycle accident reminded me of this, where you got to shoot the guy and you take your boot off to level the gun. Is that, am I remembering that correctly? Yeah, because I had gotten to it. Yeah, yeah, yeah, I had gotten to a motorcycle accident.
但你当时说，电影刚开始时有场戏，你要去……摩托车事故让我想起了这个，你要去枪杀那家伙，然后你脱下靴子来给枪当支架。是这样吗，我没记错吧？对，因为我当时遭遇了……对，对，对，我遭遇了一场摩托车事故。
And you didn't tell them, tell these guys what happened. No, two days after I got, so I was doing this small movie with Brittany Murphy, and I was having to go from, I had gotten no country, and there was no way I was gonna get no country. I even read for no country, and their only response because I was doing a movie at the time we sent in the video
而且你当时没告诉他们，你别告诉这几个人发生了什么。没有，在我出车祸两天后——当时我在拍布兰妮·墨菲的一部小成本电影，我得从……我刚拿到《老无所依》的角色，而且我本来不可能拿到《老无所依》的。我甚至为《老无所依》试读过剧本，他们唯一的反应——因为我们把视频发过去的时候我正在拍另一部电影——
and their only response was who lit it. So they didn't even comment on my act. I totally just thought it was eerily well lit. And then I got in there as the last reading and I got that part, you know, they asked me that afternoon, would you be interested in playing this part? I was like, well, hold on, let me think about it. And then I got into a motorcycle accident two days later,
他们唯一的反应是：谁打的灯？所以他们根本没对我的演技发表任何评论。我当时还完全以为是因为灯光诡异地好。然后我作为最后一个人选去试读，就拿到了那个角色，你知道的，他们那天下午问我，你有没有兴趣演这个角色？我说，好吧，等等，让我想想。结果两天后我就遭遇了一场摩托车事故，
going from one wardrobe fitting to the other and I snapped my collarbone in half. And I called them and I said, and I had prepped the doctor. I said, look, Ethan wants to talk to the doctor to find out how bad it really is. And I told the doctor, you need to tell them that's a hairline fracture. I tried to become as intimidating
当时正赶着从一个试装间去另一个试装间，我把锁骨给撞断成两截了。我打电话给他们说，而且我已经跟医生串通好了。我说，听着，伊桑想跟医生谈谈，以弄清楚伤得到底有多重。我对医生说，你必须告诉他们这只是个发丝般的微小裂缝。我试图表现得尽可能有威慑力，
as I could possibly become. I was like, you're not going to be a doctor anymore if you don't say these words in this way. And it turned out that the only reason I was able to do the role was because Lou Ellen gets shot in the right shoulder had it been the chef left shoulder I couldn't have done it. So he gets so we're in the beginning of the movie, he puts the, he's supposed to be standing up
我当时说：如果你不按这种方式说出这些话，你以后就别想当医生了。结果证明，我能演这个角色的唯一原因，是因为刘易斯是在右肩膀中枪；要是换成左肩膀，我就绝对演不了了。所以他中枪了——我们在电影开头，他本应该站着，
and shooting at the antelope. And I couldn't do it. I couldn't lift up the, because literally it had only been two weeks since I snapped my collarbone and I was letting it heal naturally. So I called somebody and there was somebody who knew a sniper in Vietnam and how could I hold the gun?
然后向羚羊开枪。而我根本做不到。我根本抬不起……因为字面意义上讲，距离我撞断锁骨才仅仅过去了两周，而且我当时正让它自然愈合。所以我打电话给某个人，那个人认识一个在越南的狙击手，我想知道我该怎么拿枪？
I love that you called somebody who knew a sniper. Sure and how could I hold the gun? I love that you called somebody who knew a sniper. Sure. Yeah. I tend to know those people. Yeah. So yeah, so that's why the boot is, I took my boot up and- And the Cone Brothers seem to like that as sort of a character choice
我太喜欢你打电话给一个认识狙击手的人了。当然，我该怎么拿枪？我太喜欢你打电话给一个认识狙击手的人了。当然。对。我往往认识这种人。对。所以，这就是为什么靴子……我脱下靴子然后……而科恩兄弟似乎很喜欢这一点，把它当成一种角色选择，
that you would use the boot or was a boot off camera? No, you see it. No, the boot's on camera. And they liked that just because it was viable. He takes his fucking boot off. Yeah. And then he balances the gun on his fucking boot because he literally can't hold the gun.
你会用到靴子，还是说靴子是在镜头之外？不，你能看到。不，靴子是在镜头里的。他们喜欢这一点，纯粹是因为它行得通。他居然把特么的靴子脱了。对。然后他把枪平衡在特么的靴子上，因为他字面意义上根本拿不动枪。
Yeah, by hand. While we're there, before we get to Sean's Dune Fiesta, anything about, the Coen brothers are just, you know, like every other person in this industry, they are my North Star and and they can do no wrong. I just, to work with them, I'm just so like, I'll take anything you can give me about what that experience is like.
对，单手拿不动。在我们继续之前，在说到肖恩的《沙丘》狂欢之前，关于——科恩兄弟简直就是，你知道的，就像这个行业的其他人一样，他们是我的北极星，他们永远不会出错。我只是，能和他们合作，我真的是……关于那种体验是怎样的，你说的任何细节我都听。
It's funny, cause I've tried to make it in the past and you're on talk shows and you're like, tell me about the Cohen's, tell me a funny story. And there's so fucking normal. The greatest thing that I have done three movies in a short with the Coens. And the greatest thing I ever got from them was after every scene I've ever done,
这很有趣，因为我过去也尝试过在脱口秀节目里聊这个，然后你会上访谈节目，别人会问：跟我聊聊科恩兄弟吧，讲个有趣的故事。而他们特么的太正常了。我和科恩兄弟合作过三部电影加一部短片，我从他们身上得到的最好的东西，就是在拍完每一个场景之后，
especially in the beginning, with the exception of one story that I'll tell you, I've never ever gotten a great scene. I've never gotten a thumbs up. Great job, right. Really, just the moving on is the confirmation. It's literally moving on and looking up and seeing their backs walking away to the next set.
尤其是在刚开始的时候——除了有一个故事我待会儿要讲——我从来、从来没有听到过“演得好”这三个字。我从来没得到过大拇指点赞。干得好，对。真的，只要说“下一场”，就是最大的肯定。字面意思就是继续下一场，然后抬头看到他们转身走向下一个片场。
No way, wow. So at best, it's like, hey, what'd you think? Like maybe later on, I'd go, you know, what'd you think of that scene? And they go, man. Yeah. Like basically it's got, it's, we got what we need. Right.
不会吧，哇。所以充其量也就是，嘿，你觉得怎么样？可能过了一会儿，我会去问：你知道的，你觉得刚才那场戏怎么样？然后他们会说：行吧。对。基本上就是，我们拿到了我们需要的镜头。对。
And you did your job correctly. Which is why we hired you. That was my dad's reaction growing up. That was your dad? Yeah. There's a trauma in that. Oh shit, he didn't have it. How would you, how would you know what his reaction was?
而且你工作完成得很出色。这就是为什么我们要雇佣你。我爸从小到大就是这种反应。那是你爸？对。这里面是有创伤的。哦靠，他没有。你怎么会……你怎么知道他的反应是什么？
Yeah. Unless you could read his mind through the rear view mirror, you know. You could read people's minds from 50 miles away. Woody Harrelson was the only guy who couldn't remember his lines during No Country, and we had that scene in the hospital together, and he talks the majority of the time. And he couldn't get through his fucking lines.
对。除非你能通过后视镜读懂他的心思，你知道的。你可以在50英里外读懂别人的心思。伍迪·哈里森是《老无所依》里唯一一个记不住台词的人，我们俩在医院里有场对手戏，大部分时间都是他在说。结果他怎么都背不顺那特么的台词。
And then when finally he did one take, where he kind of stumbled through his lines, and then I saw the Coens come from behind set and they looked up and they go, wow, that was amazing. And I was like, you gotta be fucking kidding me. It's just literally stuttering through his shit. You're holding his cue cards, right? Nothing, nothing.
然后最后当他终于拍完了一条——他磕磕巴巴地把台词念完了，接着我看到科恩兄弟从片场后面走出来，他们抬头说：哇，太惊艳了。我当时就想：你特么在逗我吧。他字面意思就是在那里结结巴巴地念台词。你在帮他拿提词卡吧？没有，什么都没有。
They were just happy they got a take. Let's be honest, so formal. Wait, so Dune, so first of all. Here we go. Okay, so wait, so arrive. So, is the sand real? Let's just start. So, okay, I'm so bored.
他们只是高兴终于拍完了一条。说实话，太正式了。等等，所以《沙丘》……首先。我们开始吧。好吧，所以等等……登场。所以，沙子是真的吗？我们先从这开始。所以，好吧，我太无聊了。
Can I talk about Dune? I can't stand in your eyes to say that. No, by the way, is it real? Is it a real place? Is it a real place? Yes. No, it's one of, no country real place? Is it a real place? Yes. No Country for Old Men is one of my favorite movies too. But Dune, I can't get, first of all,
我能聊聊《沙丘》吗？我听到你这么说简直无语了。不，顺便问一句，那是真的吗？是个真实的地方吗？是个真实的地方吗？是的。不，那是其中一个……不，《老无所依》是真的地方吗？是个真实的地方吗？是的。《老无所依》也是我最喜欢的电影之一。但是《沙丘》，我无法……首先，
Arrival is one of my favorite movies as well. Yeah, me too. Me too. So clever and well made, and the script is amazing. You're the best director. Tell Tracy why that's connected, John. Oh, because he directed,
《降临》也是我最喜欢的电影之一。对，我也是。我也是。太聪明、太棒了，剧本也绝了。你是最棒的导演。告诉特蕾西为什么这有联系，约翰。哦，因为他执导了——
the same director, director of Arrival is. Danny Vilna, right. And so, yeah. And so, D. Oh, cause he directed the same director, director to rival as Danny Veldum. Danny Veldum, right. And so, yeah. And so, so Dune, I kind of- You also directed Sicario, by the way. Yeah, and you were also great in that. Maybe we're top three. I want to get in, we'll after Dune,
同样的导演，《降临》的导演是。丹尼斯·维伦纽瓦，对吧。所以，对。所以，D。哦，因为他执导了——同样的导演，《降临》的导演是丹尼斯·维伦纽瓦。丹尼斯·维伦纽瓦，对吧。所以，对。所以，《沙丘》我有点——你还执导了《边境杀手》，顺便说一句。对，你在那部里也很棒。也许我们可以排进前三。我想聊聊，我们在《沙丘》之后，
I want to get in Sicario. Okay, so wait, so I want to know, just like Jason said, it was like the Ethan's, what's it like on that set? Where are, I mean, are they sets? Are you really in the desert? Like how much of it is it real? How much of it isn't?
我想聊聊《边境杀手》。好吧，所以等等……我想知道，就像杰森说的，伊桑的……那个片场是什么样子的？在哪里？我是说，那是实景搭设吗？你们真的是在沙漠里拍的吗？到底有多少是真的？多少不是真的？
Most of it is practical. Most of it is. That's just, just let me just pause the interview right here. Well, cause it looks like it's really in the desert. It does, doesn't it? Jason, please go on. What part gave you that impression? Was it the desert?
大部分都是实景。大部分都是。这就……让我先暂停一下采访。好吧，因为看起来真的像是在沙漠里。确实是，对吧？杰森，请继续。哪一部分给了你这种印象？是沙漠吗？
Would they be spending less money if they just green screened the whole goddamn thing? Or that maybe be a little bit more? It's actually really sweet because he's like, Oh, I'm blessed. Full fan boy right now. I'm massive, massive fan. Ask him to stand up.
如果他们把整部该死的电影都用绿幕抠图，是不是花的钱会少一点？或者可能会稍微多一点？其实真的挺搞笑的，因为他就像是：哦，我有福了。现在完全是个狂热粉丝了。我是超级、超级粉丝。叫他站起来。
You can see his pants are off. And you're so good at this. And then have him pan his camera right and you'll see Scotty just in full pole mode. Go ahead. Next question, Sean. Go ahead and finish Scotty off with the next one. Wait, so isn't it, by the way, isn't it wild that you guys had to hold the release because of the strike?
你能看到他裤子脱了。你太擅长这个了。然后让他把镜头向右摇，你就会看到斯科特完全是一副钢管舞男的姿态。继续。下一个问题，肖恩。继续用下一个问题解决掉斯科特。等等，所以难道不……顺便问一句，你们因为罢工不得不推迟上映，这不是很疯狂吗？
Speaking of holding the release. So now it's coming in March, is that what it is? Yeah, was that why? Yeah, and then we went back for reshoots in the first one during the pandemic, which we hadn't, we did it before the pandemic. What is it? Tell me what it's like working with him.
说到推迟上映。所以现在要在三月上映了，是这样吗？对，是因为这个吗？对，然后我们在第一部的第一阶段疫情期间回去进行补拍，其实我们是在疫情之前拍的。是什么样的？告诉我跟他合作是什么感觉。
And is it the opposite of the Ethan's of the Coens? I mean, he's. Well, he's also Canadian, is he not, Denny? He is Canadian, he's French Canadian. Right, so he's incredibly kind and probably effusive. Thank you. With his compliments. Thank you. Right? He's coming up giving you a little high five
这跟伊桑——跟科恩兄弟完全相反吗？我是说，他这个人……好吧，他也是加拿大人，对吧，丹尼斯？他是加拿大人，他是法裔加拿大人。没错，所以他极其善良，而且可能非常热情。谢谢。毫不吝啬他的赞美。谢谢。对吧？他会走过来跟你击个掌，
at the end of a good take. He is actually. Yes. Yeah, but what I was going to say about the Cohen's thing is that taught me a great thing and I don't really look for that anymore. I don't. But I mean, what he's accomplished in you two in Dune
在拍完一个精彩的镜头之后。他确实会这样。是的。对，但我要说的是关于科恩兄弟的那件事，它教会了我很好的一课，我以后不再去寻求那种认可了。我不再……但我是说，他在《沙丘》中对你俩的塑造——
is like it's hard to get the tone and the feel and the actors and the script and the sets and just everything works perfectly. It creates a world that we haven't seen. It's very collaborative, you know, and if I can go back to Sicario for a second, you know, I had turned down because he wasn't really an established director
真的很难把那种基调、那种感觉、演员、剧本、布景以及所有一切都完美地结合在一起。它创造了一个我们从未见过的世界。这非常具有合作性，你知道的，如果我能回到《边境杀手》再聊一会儿，你知道的，我一开始拒绝了，因为他当时并不是一个真正成名的导演，
at that point. He had done us on D. He had done one American film with Hugh Jackman. What was that film called? Not passengers, not visitors. You know what I'm saying? Yeah. About the kidnap.
他那时只拍过……他拍过一部由休·杰克曼主演的美式电影。那部电影叫什么名字？不是《劫机惊魂》，不是《宿敌》。你知道我在说什么吧？对。关于绑架案的那部。
And Jake Gyllenhaal, which was actually really good. But I said, I don't know why, because I think it was a really small part anyway, to get through this. Was Bob Elswit on board yet? I mean, I think that wasn't even in the TV. You mean Deacons. Oh, was it Deacons it did? It was Deacons.
还有杰克·吉伦哈尔，其实真的非常不错。但我说，我不知道为什么，因为我觉得反正也就是个很小的角色，为了能过关……罗杰·狄金斯当时加入了吗？我是说，我觉得当时甚至不在电视上。你是说狄金斯。哦，是狄金斯拍的吗？是狄金斯。
And I had worked with Deacons a couple of times and it was also Benicio and it was Emily Blunt. And anyway, I said no. I said no twice. And I don't know why, but and he called me and he said what every director says and lies about, which is we're going to expand this role. Right.
我和狄金斯合作过好几次，而且演员还有贝尼西奥和艾米莉·布朗特。不管怎样，我拒绝了。我拒绝了两次。我不知道为什么，但他打电话给我，说了所有导演都会说、也都在撒谎的话，那就是：我们要扩充这个角色。对。
Like what it is right now is not really what it's going to be. And you're like, we're full of shit, because I've heard that from everybody. But the truth is, and whether it was just kind of happened this way because of fate or whatever, it was so expanded. And it was so once we got on set, it was like such a vibe that all came from him, which was, this isn't working, so let we got on set it was like such a vibe that that all came from him
就像它现在这样并不是它最终的样子。而你会觉得：你们特么的满嘴跑火车，因为这种话每个人都对我说过。但事实是，不管是出于命运的安排还是别的什么原因，这个角色真的被大大扩充了。而且一旦我们到了片场，那种氛围完全是由他带动的，那就是：这行不通，所以让我们来改改这个；或者我会去敲你的拖车门，贝尼西奥不想再说话了，他觉得你应该多说台词，因为你喜欢说话。而我说：我特么演的是个完全不同的人。但我们需要这些背景交待，我们怎么才能把它变得更有行为表现力呢？诸如此类。所以这成了一个非常、非常具有合作性的过程。这就是我的感受，你知道的，丹尼斯现在是我的好朋友，但他是一个我愿意跟他合作任何项目的人，因为这种合作精神对我来说就是最高标准。
Which was this isn't working so let's work on this or I'm gonna knock on your trailer door Benicio doesn't want to talk anymore He thinks you should talk because you like to talk and I'm like I'm a different fucking character But we need this exposition. How can we make it behavioral so on and so forth? So it became a very very collaborative process. So that's what I get, you know, Denis is my good friend now, but he's a guy who I would work on anything with because that kind of collaborative effort to me is the top.
（原录音重复）这行不通，所以让我们来改改这个；或者我会去敲你的拖车门……贝尼西奥不想再说话了，他觉得你应该多说台词，因为你喜欢说话。而我说：我特么演的是个完全不同的人。但我们需要这些背景交待，我们怎么才能把它变得更有行为表现力呢？诸如此类。所以这成了一个非常、非常具有合作性的过程。这就是我的感受，你知道的，丹尼斯现在是我的好朋友，但他是一个我愿意跟他合作任何项目的人，因为这种合作精神对我来说就是最高标准。
But Sean points out like Sicario, you know, is about a world that exists, right? Like this, it's a reflection of this real world, maybe height, maybe not, I don't really know, but like of this thing, things like Dune, as? Like this, it's a reflection of this real world. Maybe height, maybe not, I don't really know, but like of this thing, things like Dune, as Sean pointed out, it's world building, right? It's creating a world.
但肖恩指出，像《边境杀手》，你知道的，讲的是一个真实存在的世界，对吧？就像这样，它是现实世界的某种反映，也许有所夸张，也许没有，我其实并不清楚，但就像这样的东西，像《沙丘》这样的作品，正如……就像这样，它是现实世界的某种反映，也许有所夸张，也许没有，我其实并不清楚，但就像这样的东西，像《沙丘》这样的作品，正如肖恩所指出的，是在进行世界构建，对吧？是在创造一个世界。
It's creating a whole thing. That's so hard to get right. Yeah, no kidding. Yeah, but there was a guy at Zev Boroh, I know from New York, and he's my good buddy, and he read through that whole series three times when he was a kid. So he knows it as well as anybody, as well as Deni does, you know three times when he was a kid, so he knows it as well as anybody,
是在创造一整个体系。要把这个做好太难了。对，可不是嘛。对，但有个叫泽夫·博罗（Zev Boroh）的家伙，我认识他，他是纽约人，也是我的好哥们儿，他小时候把那一整套书读了整整三遍。所以他比任何人都了解它，跟丹尼斯一样了解，你知道的，小时候读了三遍，所以他比任何人都了解它，
as well as Denis does, you know? And when he saw the movie, I kinda snuck him in in Santa Fe when I saw the first one, and there was a pause after the movie ended, and this guy's a 48-year-old guy, and he stood up and he started screaming, yes, that's it, yes, fuck yes! That's great, That's great. What do they call him?
跟丹尼斯一样了解，你知道的？当他在圣达菲悄悄溜进影院看第一部电影时，电影放完后有一段短暂的沉默，这家伙当时48岁了，他突然站起来大喊：对，就是这样，太棒了，特么的太棒了！太棒了，太棒了。他们怎么叫他的？
What are they, his nickname, Zeb the Virgin, right? I mean, he went through all three. He's 40. Zeb the Virgin. Wait, now that you're, now that you've had all the success and you've been working for so many years and you told us the story about how, you know, your dad had money, then didn't have money,
他们叫他什么来着，他的绰号，处男泽夫，对吧？我是说，他把三部都看完了。他都40岁了。处男泽夫。等等，既然你现在……既然你已经获得了所有的成功，并且工作了这么多年，而且你刚才给我们讲了你小时候你爸有钱、然后又没钱的故事，
had money, then didn't have money. And so kind of left you in a weird place, probably growing up. How are you with money now and handling it? Are you more responsible, and you would try to teach your kids about the responsibility of money? Yeah, it's an ongoing subject about where we live
有钱、然后又没钱。这大概让你在成长过程中处于一种奇怪的境地。你现在怎么看待金钱并处理它？你变得更有责任感了吗，你是否会试图教导你的孩子们关于金钱的责任感？对，关于我们住在哪里、这会助长什么、这会带来什么，这是一个持续讨论的话题，你知道的，鉴于我在牧场长大，鉴于我们现在拥有的牧场距离我长大的牧场只有三英里远，鉴于我们现在拥有的牧场距离我长大的牧场只有三英里远，但我经常带我的孩子们去那里，我最近也带孩子们去了。他们其实没怎么去过片场，但我去哪拍戏就把他们带到哪。
and what that promotes, and what that, you know, given that I grew up on a ranch, given that we have a ranch that's three miles away from the ranch I grew up on, ranch, given that we have a ranch that's three miles away from the ranch, I grew up on, but I take my kids there a lot, I take my kids right now. They haven't been to the set very much, but I take them wherever we shoot.
（原录音重复）鉴于我在牧场长大，鉴于我们现在拥有的牧场距离我长大的牧场只有三英里远，但我经常带我的孩子们去那里，我最近也带孩子们去了。他们其实没怎么去过片场，但我去哪拍戏就把他们带到哪。
I have a 30 year old, a 35 year old, a three year old, and a five year old. That's crazy. Wow. So. Now what kind of grandfather skills does he have? What kind of grandma skills does Babs have? I mean, what do these family get-togethers like?
我有一个30岁的、一个35岁的、一个3岁的和一个5岁的孩子。太疯狂了。哇。所以。那他有什么样的当爷爷的技巧呢？芭布斯有什么样的当奶奶的技巧呢？我是说，这些家庭聚会是什么样的？
You know, there's a real, for lack of a better word, hard on for my kids, my young kids, with said grandparents. Yeah, and really quick, just for my sister, and I'm just saying this for my sister, Josh. Yeah, no you're not. Your dad is James Brolin who's married to Barbara Streisand. No, really?
你知道的，换个说法，我那些小孩子们对所谓的爷爷奶奶有着一种——借用一个不太恰当的词——狂热的迷恋。对，顺便说一下，为了我妹妹，我这么说纯粹是为了我妹妹，乔什。不，你才不是。你爸是詹姆斯·布洛林，他娶了芭芭拉·史翠珊。真的吗？
Yeah, yeah, no, you should call him. Yeah, it's amazing. That's it. Go dad. It's for my sister and for my sister, Tracy. But they're keyed in on these two. Was it different than the first two kids? Like they got another crack at it.
对，对，不，你应该给他打个电话。对，这太棒了。就这样。老爸加油。这是为了我妹妹，为了我妹妹特蕾西。但他们对这两个小家伙非常上心。这跟前两个孩子有什么不同吗？就像他们又有了新机会一样？
I think in my first two kids, definitely, they laugh at it now where they were like, we're still here, by the way. But the young kids are very cute. And I think that they're at an age now where things have slowed down enough where you start to appreciate those Familiy etc etc, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, that's great What would you say is the biggest difference between your fathering on the first two versus the the second two?
我想对我的前两个孩子来说，绝对不同。他们现在回想起来还会笑，当时他们觉得：顺便说一句，我们还在呢。但小孩子们非常可爱。而且我觉得他们现在到了这样一个年龄：生活节奏已经慢了下来，足以让你开始appreciate（欣赏）那些家庭时光等等，对吧？对。对。对。太棒了。你觉得你对前两个孩子的父亲教育和后两个孩子的父亲教育之间最大的区别是什么？
What would have you yeah? You've got a little little lighter blend on the on blend on your hydration this round. I mean, that's just the fucking truth, man. I mean, I was in and out and that kind of thing, but you know, I mean, I think it's okay to say this. Even though it's an anonymous program, my son's sober, my daughter's married to a sober dude. That's great. My wife's sober. I love that.
你会有什么……这一轮你的情绪管理稍微轻松了一点，对吧。我是说，这特么就是事实，老兄。我是说，我以前总是聚少离多之类的事情，但你知道的，我是说，我觉得说出来也没关系。尽管这是一个匿名互助项目，但我儿子戒酒了，我女儿嫁给了一个戒酒的帅哥。太棒了。我老婆也戒酒了。我太喜欢这样了。
I love that. Right. So they learned a lot from your mistakes or your... Hopefully, in all honesty, you know what I mean? I think we were all pretty open. I tried not to let the thing cross over and it did cross over a few times and we talk about it, but it's a very open dialogue with us. When you mentioned about you getting kicked out
我太喜欢了。对。所以他们从你的错误或者你的……中学到了很多东西？说实话，希望如此，你知道我的意思吗？我觉得我们都挺坦诚的。我尽量不让那些事影响到他们，虽然确实有几次影响到了，我们也经常谈论这个，但我们之间是一个非常开放的对话机制。当提到你16岁时因为嘴欠之类的原因被赶出家门，
at 16 years old because of your mouth and stuff, do you recognize the signs and any of your kids that they kind of might repeat the same behavior that you did when you were born? No, because I think mine was so extreme that it was definitely a warning light as opposed to let me try and emulate that to see if I can pull that off. Uh-huh, right, right. We'll be right back. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp.
你会在你的任何孩子身上看到这样的迹象吗——他们可能会重复你年轻时做过的那些行为？不会，因为我觉得我当年的行为太极端了，那绝对是一个警告信号，而不是让我去效仿看看自己能不能做到。呃，对，对。我们马上回来。本节目由BetterHelp赞助播出。
You know, everybody, including myself, is always like, God, there's not enough hours in the day. I have so much to do. I can't find even five minutes. But I think if we're being honest with ourselves, we can probably find an hour, right? If you're really willing to do that, you can probably find an hour for yourself. The question is for everyone, time for what? Right? If time was unlimited, how would you use it? How would you decide what's
你知道，每个人，包括我自己，总是觉得：天哪，一天的时间根本不够用。我有那么多事情要做。我甚至连五分钟都抽不出来。但我想如果我们对自己诚实一点，我们大概还是能抽出一个小时的，对吧？如果你真的愿意这么做，你大概能为自己抽出一个小时。问题是，每个人都在问：时间拿来干嘛？对吧？如果时间是无限的，你会怎么利用它？你将如何决定什么才是
important enough to make time for? So therapy can help you find what matters to you so you can do more of it. So if you, when talking to a therapist, you discover, you know what, I always want to, I wish I was riding bikes more, like actually out on the street. That's one of my things. I'm like, if I had a bike, I would actually ride it. Anyway, I'm rambling. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule.
重要到值得你为之腾出时间？所以心理治疗可以帮你找到对你真正重要的东西，这样你就能花更多时间去做了。所以如果你在与心理治疗师交谈时发现：你知道吗，我其实一直想骑自行车，真的想去马路上骑车。这是我的愿望之一。我觉得：要是我有一辆自行车，我肯定会去骑。总之，我扯远了。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在提供便捷、灵活的服务，并且完全迎合你的日程安排。
Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Learn to make time for what makes you happy with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlist today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash smartlist. Smartlist is brought to you in part by Rakuten. Think of the last time you bought something to wear.
只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与一位有执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。通过BetterHelp学会为你热爱的事情腾出时间。今天就访问 betterhelp.com/smartlist，首月即可享受九折优惠。网址是 betterhelp.com/smartlist。Smartlist 部分内容由 Rakuten 赞助播出。想想你最近一次买衣服是什么时候。
Something to decorate your house, something for your family or friends. What if each time you made a purchase, you got a little something back with Rakuten? You can. You can earn cash back on just about anything you buy from over 750 stores. If you've ever bought electronics, home decor, fashion, beauty, or booked a trip, well, you could have gotten cash back. But do not worry, it's not too late. It's free and easy to use and you get cash back deposited in your PayPal account or sent to you as a check.
买点装饰房子的东西，或者为家人朋友买礼物。如果你每次购物都能通过 Rakuten 获得一点返现呢？你可以的。你在750多家商店购买几乎任何东西都可以赚取现金返现。如果你曾经买过电子产品、家居装饰、时尚美妆或者预订过旅行，那你本可以拿到现金返现的。但别担心，现在还不晚。它免费且易于使用，返现可以直接存入你的 PayPal 账户或以支票形式寄给你。
Earn cash back at stores like Sephora, Old Navy, and Expedia. It is the smartest way to shop, plain and simple. Start your shopping at racketon.ca or get the Racketon app. That's R-A-K-U-T-E-N. And now, back to the show. You know what's funny, Josh?
在 Sephora、Old Navy 和 Expedia 等商店购物都能赚取返现。这是最聪明的购物方式，简单明了。请访问 racketon.ca 或下载 Rakuten 应用开始购物。拼写是 R-A-K-U-T-E-N。现在，我们回到节目中。你知道最搞笑的是什么吗，乔什？
The other day I was reading this story in the Wall Street Journal. These guys don't know what that is, but there was a story about... Smart list. About weed. There was a story about weed and it was saying how they've seen an uptick in kids having psychotic breaks
前几天我在《华尔街日报》上看到这样一篇报道。这几位压根不知道那是什么，但上面有一篇报道……Smart list。关于大麻的。有一篇关于大麻的报道，上面说跟10年、20年相比，他们发现青少年因大麻导致精神崩溃的比例有所上升。所以我把它发给了我前妻。我立刻把截图发给艾米了，结果她说：你为什么给我发这个？而我们的两个大儿子当时13岁和15岁。我说：因为大麻现在太容易得到了，周围到处都是这东西，我对此非常焦虑。我当时就是有这种……你知道我的意思吗？
as a result of cannabis as compared to 10, 20 years ago. So I send it to my ex. I text it to Amy like immediately and she goes, why are you sending me this? And our older sons are 13 and 15. And I go, because weed is very readily available, and there are things around, and I'm very nervous about it. Like I just had this, you know what I mean?
（原录音重复）因为大麻现在太容易得到了，周围到处都是这东西，我对此非常焦虑。我当时就是有这种……你知道我的意思吗？
It wasn't like- But I understand, it was like, remember back in the 70s, I remember I was a friend of my dad's in Passerobles, and I was on the floor or something, and I looked under his bed, and I found a drawer, a pot, and I rolled it up in some writing paper, and tried to smoke it when I got home and I was like eight or nine.
这倒不是说——但我理解，就像……还记得70年代的时候吗，我记得我在帕索罗布尔斯（Paso Robles）一个我爸的朋友家，我当时趴在地毯上还是干嘛，结果我翻了翻他床底下，发现了一个装大麻的抽屉，然后我用写字纸把它卷起来，等回到家后试着抽了一口，那时我才八九岁吧。
But even if I was able to smoke it, the high would have been, you wouldn't have been that high. Right, you smoke a full joint nowadays, you gotta call your mom. One hit nowadays. Oh no, no, no, yeah, yeah, yeah. Before I got sober, I remember,
但就算我当时真抽成了，那种劲儿也……你根本不会觉得有多上头。对，现在你要是抽完一整根，你就得打电话叫妈妈了。现在只要抽一口。哦不，不，不，对，对，对。在我戒酒之前，我记得，
I loved the idea of dispensaries and I loved the idea behind the science and it all. And I was like, what does this do? And where did this and how do you make this? I made it for the science too. Yeah, I know, I get it. But there was a guy, he was from Poland and we kind of would go through this whole thing
我非常喜欢药房的概念，我也很喜欢背后的科学原理什么的。当时我就想：这东西是干嘛用的？这东西是从哪来的？又是怎么制作的？我研究它也是为了科学。对，我知道，我懂。但当时有个家伙，他是波兰人，我们俩经常经历这么一出，
and I would pretend like I didn't smoke because I didn't really love smoking very much. And then I would give it to my friends. But then one night, I was home alone and I was supposed to read this essay that my daughter had done. And I went outside and I was like, well, maybe I'll try it. I'll just try a little bit.
我会假装自己不抽大麻，因为我其实并不怎么喜欢抽。然后我会把它送给我的朋友。但有天晚上，我独自在家，本来应该读一篇我女儿写的文章。我走到外面心想：好吧，也许我可以试试。我就试那么一小口。
And I took a little hit and I got too much smoke. And then I coughed it out. And by the time I had exhaled, I was convinced that there were cross hairs from across the building on my head, and I was slowly lowering behind my... You know, army crawl back into the house? Yeah, and then I tried to read the essay, and I read the same first line about 125 times.
结果我吸了一小口，吸进去了太多烟。然后我把它咳出来了。就在我呼出那口烟的同时，我确信有一把来自对面大楼的狙击枪十字准星正对准我的脑袋，于是我慢慢地蹲下去，藏到……你知道的，以爬行的方式溜回了屋里？对，然后我试着去读那篇文章，结果同一行第一句话我读了大约125遍。
And that was one hit, man. So I get it. You needed to get into the edibles. It's heavy duty. Sean, Sean, I love it when Sean gets on. I love it. Well, Jason, his book is coming out and it's about edibles. But he's written the first line 120 times.
而那仅仅是一口，老兄。所以我懂。你当时需要去尝试食用大麻食品（edibles）了。那玩意儿劲太大了。肖恩，肖恩，我太喜欢肖恩一聊这个的时候了。我太喜欢了。好吧，杰森，他的书快出版了，主题就是关于大麻食品的。但他把第一句话写了120遍。
Sean, when Sean gets on weed, it is my fate. When you get on weed, who's old? But when Sean smokes weed or takes an edible, it's the funniest. It makes me laugh, Sean, anytime. Well, I get like tunneling. As he's getting to the hospital. And I get spurts of little energy.
肖恩，当肖恩碰大麻的时候，那就是我的命啊。当你碰大麻的时候，谁老了？但每当肖恩抽大麻或者吃大麻食品时，那绝对是最好笑的。肖恩，不管什么时候都能把我逗笑。好吧，我会有那种隧道视觉。随着他赶往医院。而且我会爆发出一阵阵短暂的精力。
But wait, like when I was a kid, I was so afraid of doing anything wrong. Like I was, I remember, I was scared about having a library book out too long. And I thought I was gonna get into massive trouble. Where does it come, where does that come from? Where you're like, yeah, I'll try this. I'll do this. I'll get in this trouble.
但等等，我小时候特别害怕做错任何事。就像我记得，我曾经因为一本图书馆的书借得太久而感到害怕。我以为自己会惹上大麻烦。这是从哪来的，这种性格是从哪来的？让你觉得：对，我要试试这个。我要干这个。我要惹上这个麻烦。
I'll beat the shit out of this kid. I'll smoke this stuff. Like what is that? I never beat the shit out of a kid. I was never that guy, you know? I bullies maybe, but I was never, even though we all fought a lot, but it was, that was the culture.
我要狠狠地揍这小子一顿。我要抽这玩意儿。这到底是什么心理？我从来没狠狠揍过一个小屁孩。我从不是那种人，你知道的？也许欺负过恶霸，但我也从不……尽管我们以前经常打架，但这是一种文化。
That was the culture that I grew up in in punk rock and all that kind of stuff. Back when parents were doing blow instead of parenting. Imagine what a bummer it would be to get into a fight with Brolin, it would fucking suck. At any age. At any age. I'll bet at eight he could really square you up. I went over there, I went over to Brolin, remember I came over to try your coal puns like five years ago and we got in the fucking coal puns and he's a couple years old With me. I was like look how fucking stacked this motherfucker Baby
那是我在朋克摇滚及诸如此类的环境中长大的那代人的文化。回到过去父母只顾自己嗑药、根本不管孩子生长的年代。想象一下，要是跟布洛林打一架得有多扫兴啊，那特么绝对糟透了。任何年龄段都是。任何年龄段。我敢说他八岁时就能把你打得服服帖帖的。我以前去过那儿，我去过布洛林家，还记得大约五年前我去试过你的冰浴吗，结果我们泡进了那特么的冰浴里，而他比我大好几岁。当时我就想：看看这个肌肉发达的母体……宝贝，
Are you in better shape now than you've ever been in your life? I'll be I was I was in better shape during dune than I've been in in a very very long time I think I did when I did Deadpool 2, I think that's the best shape I've ever been in. Sean, cool it. I'm just saying, it's good looking. But you still do the martial arts and have you ever in or would you and can I promote you and Downey
你现在的身材是不是你这辈子最好的状态？我敢说，我在拍《沙丘》期间的身材是我很长一段时间以来最好的。我觉得我拍《死侍2》的时候，那大概是我身材达到巅峰的时候。肖恩，冷静点。我只是说，看起来很帅嘛。但你现在还在练武术吗？你有没有过、或者你愿不愿意——我能不能帮你和唐尼宣传一下，
fighting each other? I would do that. I was just with Downey and we were talking about you two days ago. I'm gonna fucking pop that up. Wait, can I get in on that, Arnett? Yeah, I'm getting it running down. Downey, Brolin Brolin fight. Well let's do it in, do we think Vegas Atlantic City or what about Laughlin? Laughlin would be kind of
让他们俩打一架？我绝对愿意。我前天刚和唐尼在一起，我们还聊到你呢。我特么一定要把这事炒作起来。等等，阿内特，我也能加入吗？对，我这就去安排。唐尼对阵布洛林，世纪大战。那我们去哪打呢？你觉得是拉斯维加斯、大西洋城，还是劳克林（Laughlin）？劳克林听起来挺奇特的，对吧？
kitschy right? Remember that wasn't there like an animated thing like celebrity fights or something like that? It was like a claymation thing. Yeah look it up afterwards. It was super fun. I'd like to make that a reality. Oh, that's right. There was a Claymation show. Yeah. I'm bored with the acting. I want to fuck celebrities out. There's that clip. I would fucking, I am backing you, Brolin. You're my fucking dog in this one. Wait, Josh, do you know Brendan Shanahan? He's a friend of Will's. He's a hockey player. He's a hockey player. Retired hockey player, president of the Toronto Maple Leafs, one of the all time great guys. So Will and Brendan and I were out to dinner.
记得以前是不是有个叫什么“名人拳击”的动画节目来着？类似于黏土动画那种。对，你回头查查。超级好玩。我挺想把它变成现实的。哦，对。以前确实有个黏土动画秀。对。我对演戏已经厌倦了，我想把名人们全打趴下。有个剪辑片段。我绝对挺你，布洛林。在这场比赛里你就是我的铁子。等等，乔什，你认识布伦丹·沙纳汉（Brendan Shanahan）吗？他是威尔的朋友。他是冰球运动员。他是个冰球运动员。退役冰球运动员，多伦多枫叶队总裁，史上最伟大的家伙之一。所以威尔、布伦丹和我当时一起出去吃晚饭。
This is a few weeks ago. And I said to Brendan Shanahan, who's been in, you know, a thousand fights on the ice rink. He holds the record for the most what they call Gordy Howe hat tricks, which is goal assistant fight in a game. Right. So I told him, I always had this a little tiny, tiny, tiny bit of a fantasy of getting in a fight
这是几个星期前的事。我对布伦丹·沙纳汉说——他在冰球场上打过成千上万场架。他保持着获得最多所谓“戈迪·豪帽子戏法”的纪录，也就是在一场比赛里同时完成进球、助攻和打架。对。所以我告诉他，我一直有那么一点点、微乎其微的幻想，想要去打一次架，
because I've never been in a fist fight, right? We'll see on the receiving end, right? Just getting beat to shit. Yeah, literally in hockey fights for you, just grab somebody. What if you pull my hair right before you? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, like that. You know, that's what it's like.
因为我从来没在现实中跟人打过拳击，对吧？我们看的是挨打的那一方，对吧？就是被打得屁滚尿流。对，字面意义上讲，在冰球比赛里打架，你就是抓住别人。如果你在我动手前揪我头发呢？对，对，对，对，就像那样。你知道，就是那种感觉。
By the way, it's borderline fetish, but go ahead. No, no, just because I don't know. I would pardon me, just want to know what that feels like. And so Brendan, Brendan takes me out. I'm gonna make that happen. So Brendan takes me out and grabs me and he's teaching me how to fight. And in two, and I can't stop smiling because I think it's so funny.
顺便说一句，这已经快赶上某种恋物癖了，但你继续。不，不，纯粹是因为我不知道。恕我直冒犯，我只是想知道那是什么感觉。所以布伦丹、布伦丹把我拉出去。我要把这事变成现实。所以布伦丹把我拉出去，抓住我，教我怎么打架。结果在两秒钟之内——我根本停不下来笑，因为我觉得太搞笑了。
And he goes, first of all, wipe that fucking smile off your face, because you're going to get into a fight. And how'd you feel? How'd you feel when he said that? You got scared? Made me laugh harder. Yeah, he's like, stop looking like you're going to enjoy this, god damn it.
然后他说：首先，把脸上那特么的笑容收起来，因为你马上就要挨打了。当时你感觉怎么样？他这么说的时候你感觉怎么样？你害怕了吗？这反而把我逗得笑得更厉害了。对，他就像是在说：别摆出一副很享受的样子，该死的。
So he grabs me in some crazy hold in two seconds flat. I can't move my entire body. And he's like, this is you would be dead. So you had just beat the shit out of your face. He had his arm wrapped around. And then I would just start filling you in like this. And he just's like, this is, you would be dead. So you'd just beat the shit out of your face. He had his arm wrapped around, and then I would just start filling you in like this. And he just starts going, Sean's laughing and he did say, by the way,
于是他用一个疯狂的锁喉把我制服了，两秒钟都不到。我全身都动弹不得。他说：换作别人你现在已经死了。所以你的脸当时就肿了。他把胳膊缠在我脖子上，然后我就会开始像这样痛扁你。接着他就开始……肖恩笑得不行，而且他当时确实说过，顺便说一句，
it's at the back entrance, that little back side door behind the polo lounge. There's nothing more elitist than that scenario. Lord, what about MMA kind of stuff? Are you training with that too? Like could you, is that your skill set or is it more martial arts? I think it was, martial arts no longer,
就在那个后门，波罗酒廊（Polo Lounge）后面那个小侧门。没有比这更具有精英主义色彩的情景了。天哪，那综合格斗（MMA）之类的呢？你也在练那个吗？比如那是你的技能包之一，还是更偏向于传统武术？我觉得是……武术已经不练了，
even though I nut, like the Gracie's, become good friends and through Laird Hamilton and all that and I have massive respect for them. But no, I think the getting in shape, MMA, Dana White's a really close friend of mine. I love MMA, I've always loved boxing. I didn't think MMA would last or UFC would last and it has and it's incredible and I get very into it.
尽管我和格雷西家族（Gracies）成了很好的朋友，通过莱尔德·汉密尔顿（Laird Hamilton）他们认识的，我对他们充满敬意。但我觉得，保持身材、MMA、白大拿（Dana White）是我的至交好友。我喜欢MMA，我一直都很喜欢拳击。我以前没觉得MMA或UFC能持久，但它确实坚持下来了，而且难以置信，我非常沉迷其中。
Have a lot of guys come over to my house. We just built this extra kind of MMA barn. What time? You can watch MMA on what? What time? What time? What time? I'll invite you. You know what's funny, Josh is all this stuff You can watch MMA on what? What time? What time? What time?
经常有一帮人来我家。我们刚刚建了这个额外的MMA训练仓库。几点？你在什么地方看MMA？几点？几点？几点？
I'll invite you. You know what's funny, Josh, is all this stuff, and you do a lot of this stuff, and you're very in shape and whatever, but over the last couple of years, I have noticed, and I think you mentioned going to listen to poetry years ago, but anybody who follows you on Instagram or anybody who gets texts from you,
我邀请你。你知道最搞笑的是，乔什，所有这些事情——你在什么地方看MMA？几点？几点？几点？我邀请你。你知道最搞笑的是，乔什，所有这些事情，你做了很多这样的事，而且你身材保持得非常好什么的，但在过去几年里，我注意到——我想你几年前提到过要去听诗朗诵，但任何在Instagram上关注你的人，或者任何收到你发来的短信的人，
talking about your day or the things that you're grateful for, i.e. gratitude lists, knows that you've kind of veered into that. As much of a guy you like to sort of mix it up, you've also become quite, and maybe this is just a result of older age and having younger kids again, you've become quite ponderous. You've become quite, you're really appreciating the world
谈论你的一天或者你感激的事情，比如心存感激的清单，知道你有点偏向于那个方向。尽管你喜欢把各种事情混在一起，但你也有点，也许这只是年纪大了又有了小孩子的必然结果，你变得相当沉思。你变得相当，你真的很欣赏这个世界
around you in a way that's pretty astound. I know, I'm gonna make out with you now too. He's got that soft, chewy center. But it's true, man. You do, like every day you talk about, and you talk about things you really open about, appreciating your wife, loving your wife, loving your kids. You're really open about it. And I think there's something super, super, super nice
以一种非常惊人的方式环绕着你。我知道，我现在也要跟你亲热一下。他内心其实很柔软温情。但这是真的，老兄。你确实是这样，就像你每天都在谈论，而且你谈论的事情非常坦诚，欣赏你的妻子，爱你的妻子，爱你的孩子。你对此真的非常坦诚。我觉得这里面有一种超级、超级、超级美好
and vulnerable and beautiful about that. Thanks. I appreciate that very much. I don't think it's a new thing, but I think it's ramped up recently because I love the idea of contrast in the fact that I ride a vintage motorcycle or with a group of dudes or the fact that I'm perceived as this scrappy gnarly whatever, Ultraman, the last man in Hollywood.
且脆弱又美丽的东西。谢谢。我非常感激。我不认为这是一件新鲜事，但我认为它最近有所增加，因为我喜欢对比的概念，事实上我骑着一辆老式摩托车，或者和一群哥们儿在一起，或者事实上我被视为一个坚韧不拔、饱经风霜的什么乱七八糟的人，超级铁人，好莱坞的最后一个硬汉。
Oh, that's right. But then what is the count? It should be noted that Josh is smiling when he says that. Yeah, he's smiling. That I love the idea of contrasting that with, because there is an incredible sensitivity and I do love my kids. I will be raising, I had my first kid when I was 20
哦，对哦。但总数是多少？需要指出的是，乔希说这话时在笑。对，他在笑。我喜欢将其与这种概念进行对比，因为有一种不可思议的敏感度，我确实很爱我的孩子。我会把他们抚养成人，我20岁时有了第一个孩子，
and my youngest, I'll be 70 when she graduates high school. Wow, so cool. And I love it, man. I love it in the writing. What would be the contrasting thing that would surprise most people? Like what is the softest thing that you do on a regular basis?
而我最小的孩子，她高中毕业时我都70岁了。哇，太酷了。我太喜欢了，老兄。我在写作中也喜欢这样。能让大多数人感到惊讶的对比会是什么？比如你经常做的最温柔的事是什么？
Okay, here's a story. Here's a story, and I don't know if this is the best story to tell, but the story, when we went to Atlanta and during the pandemic, we kind of moved to Atlanta where my wife is from. And nothing against Atlanta, but when I got to Atlanta, I realized I was in Atlanta.
好吧，我给你讲个故事。我讲个故事，我不知道这算不算一个适合讲的故事，但是那个故事，当我们去亚特兰大时，在疫情期间，我们搬到了我妻子所在的亚特兰大。我对亚特兰大没有什么意见，但当我到了亚特兰大时，我意识到我身处亚特兰大。
I didn't realize Atlanta was in Atlanta, so I couldn't stay. But I was sitting there in such a nice house and I'm looking out the window and I see this kind of barrel-chested, tattooed, huge, goateed, tattooed guy in the middle of my yard and he's kind of looking up at a tree.
我之前没意识到亚特兰大原来是这样的，所以我待不下去了。但我当时坐在这么一所漂亮的房子里，我向窗外望去，看到一个胸膛宽阔、满身纹身、身材高大、留着山羊胡、满身纹身的家伙正站在我院子中央，他抬头看着一棵树。
And I go, who the fuck is that? And I open the door and I go, hey man, and he looks at me and he goes, hey. And I go, yeah, what the fuck are you doing in my yard? And he looks at me and there's a long pause and he goes, I'm your gardener. And I go, oh fuck, I'm so sorry. And I went down there and I started talking to him.
我说，这他妈是谁啊？我打开门说，嘿，伙计。他看着我说，嘿。我说，没错，你他妈在我的院子里干什么？他看着我，沉默了很久，然后说，我是你的园丁。我说，哦操，真是对不起。我走过去开始跟他聊天。
And within 15 minutes, and I'm not kidding, I'm not exaggerating, within 15 minutes, he and I are in a total embrace, tears falling down our cheeks. Wow. And it turns out that he's 24 years sober. He runs the biggest sober biker club that's an international biker club in the world.
不到15分钟，我不是在开玩笑，我没有夸大其词，不到15分钟，我和他就紧紧相拥，热泪盈眶。哇。原来他已经戒酒24年了。他管理着全世界最大的国际机车俱乐部。
That's amazing. He's one of my best friends now. I love that. So I love the idea of this cosmetic thing that you immediately judge and then underneath it is whatever we're doing. I love that. Well, the biggest compliment I can give you
太棒了。他现在是我最好的朋友之一。我太喜欢了。我喜欢这种表面上你会立刻妄加评判，而在其表面之下，无论我们做什么。我喜欢这个。好吧，我能给你的最大赞美是
is I've never met you before. This is the first time. And you're completely, I feel completely at ease with you. I feel like I've known you forever. You seem so open and just normal down to earth and honest. And please put me in a chokehold. I'm sorry, I didn't know. And can you please keep putting me in a chokehold?
我以前从没见过你。这是第一次。你完全，我跟你在一起感到完全轻松。我觉得我好像认识你一辈子了。你看起来那么开放，而且很正常、脚踏实地、诚实。请把我锁喉吧。对不起，我不知道。你能继续把我锁喉吗？
Maybe the best time joke of all time. And I want to spoon with you. You seem like the guy that would be really cool to spoon. Are you in New York by the way? Are you in... Sean, are you in New York? I'm in Los Angeles. You're in Los Angeles. My wife saw your play. I did not, admittedly. But my wife saw your play, which I heard was... Oh, please tell her thank you. You were truly a revelation.
也许是有史以来最好的时代笑话。我想和你勺子式拥抱。你看起来就是那种抱起来会很爽的家伙。顺便问一下，你在纽约吗？你在……肖恩，你在纽约吗？我在洛杉矶。你在洛杉矶。我妻子看了你的话剧。说实话，我没看。但我妻子看了你的话剧，我听说……哦，请代我向她道谢。你真是一个启示。
Oh, that's very nice. It was... Honestly, it was so. Oh, that's very nice. It was, honestly, it was so, no, I know, Sean, fuck off, fuck off, it was so good. It deserves to get mentioned whenever we talk about it. It was so, so very good. Oh, speaking of Josh, you got any horrible, tragic theater stories?
哦，那太好了。那是……老实说，太……哦，那太好了。那是，老实说，太，不，我知道，肖恩，滚开，滚开，太棒了。每当我们谈起它时，它都值得被提及。它真的，真的很棒。哦，说到乔希，你有什么可怕的、悲惨的剧院故事吗？
Something that just went horribly wrong? You know, no, man, but just theater, theater is such a, it's a funny thing, You know, no man, but just theater, theater is such a, it's a funny thing. You know, it's like, my experience of theater is like you fucking people in Hollywood. Right. You're such phonies, you're such vakes, you don't understand the real thing.
有什么事情彻底搞砸了吗？你知道，没有，老兄，但只是剧院，剧院就是这样一个，这是一件很有趣的事，你知道，没有，老兄，但只是剧院，剧院就是这样一个，这是一件很有趣的事。你知道，这就像，我对剧院的体验就像你们这些好莱坞的混蛋。对。你们这群伪君子，你们这些虚伪的家伙，你们根本不懂真实的东西。
And then that person three days later, you'll see it in like an El Pollo local commercial. Oh right, exactly. Or like, I'm coming out in March for pilot season, you got an extra bag? Yeah, literally. I find it the most hypocritical society I've ever, you know what I mean?
然后三天后，那个人，你会在某个波罗本地广告里看到他。哦对，没错。或者像，我三月份要来参加试播季，你有多余的行李箱吗？是的，真的。我发现这是我见过最虚伪的社会，你知道我的意思吗？
And I love it, and I just wrote a play, and we're trying to get that play done in Ohio, and it's really good, but I'm reminded again and again how much I hate the theater community. I'm just kidding, I'm totally kidding. That's really good, but I'm reminded again and again how much I hate the theater community. I'm just kidding, I'm totally kidding. He's totally kidding. One of my favorite questions, and we'll let you go, is with all of the incredible set experience that you have
我爱死它了，我刚写了一部剧本，我们正试图在俄亥俄州把那部剧排出来，它真的很棒，但我一次又一次地被提醒，我是多么讨厌戏剧界。我开玩笑的，我完全是在开玩笑。这真的很棒，但我一次又一次地被提醒，我是多么讨厌戏剧界。我开玩笑的，我完全是在开玩笑。他完全是在开玩笑。我最喜欢的问题之一，我们就让你走吧，凭着你所有丰富的片场经验
and all the incredible directors you've worked with, have you ever been tempted to take all of that, which you've cherry picked from them, and sit in the chair yourself and direct something? You know, it's funny you would bring this up and I'm curious why you would bring it up because I was gonna bring it up regardless of whether you brought it up or not
以及你合作过的所有优秀的导演，你有没有想过把从他们身上精挑细选的所有这些东西拿过来，自己坐在导演椅上导演点东西？你知道，你提起这个挺有意思的，我很好奇你为什么要提这个，因为不管你提不提，我本来都打算提的
but I reached out to you when I directed an episode of Outer Range which is something that I did with Amazon. Yeah. And a very strange kind of Western contemporary Western. And, you know, it's something that I've always wanted to do. I've directed theater. I've never directed, I directed a short,
但我联系你了，当我执导了一集《外围》的时候，那是我和亚马逊合作的一部作品。对。那是一个非常奇怪的西部片，当代西部片。而且，你知道，这是我一直想做的事情。我导演过戏剧。我从未导演过，我导演过一部短片，
but I've never directed something that was substantial and with money. And I reached out to you and I said, You were just thinking about it at the time, weren't you? I was thinking about it at the time. And I reached out to you and I said, you know, do you have any advice for me? And which I thought was really interesting.
但我从来没有导演过实质性的、有资金支持的东西。我联系了你，我说，你当时只是在考虑，对吧？我当时正在考虑。我联系了你，我说，你知道，你有什么建议给我吗？我觉得这真的很有趣。
Like why would I reach out to you? So obviously my respect for you. Who do you think you've called? No, but I love that I reached out to you and you said a great thing. You were like, don't, focus on the day players. You said, don't forget about the day players. That was one bit of advice that you gave me,
为什么我要联系你？所以显然我对你很尊敬。你以为你给谁打过电话？不，但我很高兴我联系了你，你说了件很棒的事。你说，不要，专注于特约演员。你说，别忘了特约演员。那是你给我的建议之一，
but you were so sweet and so kind of you kind of. And Tracy, the day players are the actors that are doing the parts that are not the starring roles. Maybe one line, three lines. Yeah, sometimes they're cast right from the local city that you're shooting in. And there's an instinct sometimes for them to potentially overplay their scene because they're only in a couple of scenes and sometimes
但你太好了，而且你有点……崔西，特约演员就是那些扮演非主角的演员。可能只有一句台词，三句台词。对，有时他们直接从你拍摄的当地城市挑选。有时他们有一种本能，可能会在场景中过度表演，因为他们只出现在几个场景中，有时
there's a directing. Which can take you right out of a scene. Right, yeah. And so is it directing? Which was your point, I think. Right. So how did that go? Really, really well. And I have to say that directing, and I know a lot of probably actors feel like this, it wasn't an opportunity to finally do the thing that I wanted to do that no director wouldn't let me do. But it was more that the myriad interests
会有导演指导。这会让你瞬间跳戏。对，没错。所以是导演指导吗？我想这就是你的重点。对。那进展如何？非常，非常顺利。我必须说，导演，我知道很多演员可能都有这种感觉，这并不是一个终于去做我一直想做而没有导演让我做的事情的机会。但更多的是，我一生中经历的种种兴趣
that I've had in my lifetime that I never really understood all made sense suddenly. It was like I can utilize everything I've ever been interested in, everything that I've wanted to randomly learn and didn't know why now makes perfect sense. When you're available to somebody in the way that they need you to be available,
我以前从未真正理解的，突然间都说得通了。这就像我可以利用我曾经感兴趣的一切，我一直想随机学习的一切，而以前不知道为什么，现在完全说得通了。当你以某种方式对某人有求必应时，
which changes from actor to actor and staff members, whatever, DP or whatever, and say, how can I be most helpful as opposed to how can I make my mark and you know Use my power because now I finally have it right Exactly, you know you think about doing it again perhaps I think that's the I think out of that has come a real interest in finding foreign directors right now and finding projects like that and really focusing on on
这种方式因演员和剧组人员而异，无论是摄影指导还是其他人，然后说，我怎样才能最帮忙，而不是我该如何树立威信，你知道的，运用我的权力，因为现在我终于拥有了权力。对，没错，你知道，你考虑过再次尝试吗？我想这就是，我想由此产生了一种真正的兴趣，那就是现在寻找外国导演，寻找这样的项目，并真正专注于
Another echelon of great directors. And yes, I would like to think that I would further that. I think it would be dumb not to. I think the only reason why it wouldn't happen is out of fear. And I'm kind of at 55, I'm kind of done with the idea of fear. But I was gonna say, the thing that Jason says to a lot of people and he talks about experience on set
另一个级别的伟大导演。是的，我想我会把这个进行下去。我觉得不这样做就太蠢了。我认为唯一不会发生的理由就是出于恐惧。而我已经55岁了，我有点厌倦了恐惧的概念。但我想说的是，杰森对很多人说过的话，他谈到了在片场的经验
and you've been doing it a long time. You do have so much experience, and you do have such a point of view, and that's important as a director, obviously as we all know, and I'm surprised that it's not something that you're like actively doing more because you do have such a strong point of view.
你已经干了很长时间了。你确实有这么多的经验，你确实有这样的观点，这对于一个导演来说是很重要的，显然正如我们都知道的那样，我很惊讶这不是一件你更积极去做的事情，因为你确实有这么强烈的观点。
And know how, an incredible experience and comfort on a set in order to lead, you know? But I think it's also the fact, and I think this has to do with raising kids, is you're not afraid to be wrong, because you understand that wrong doesn't really pertain. You just have to make a decision. And you have to allow other people
并且知道诀窍，在片场拥有不可思议的经验和舒适感以便能够领导，你知道吗？但我认为这也是事实，而且我认为这与抚养孩子有关，那就是你不怕犯错，因为你明白犯错其实并不重要。你只需要做出决定。你必须允许其他人
to be able to lean on you, and stand behind your decisions, and know that it's not gonna be perfect and know that you're gonna have to compensate and know that you may have to fix some things in editing and all that kind of stuff. I just think it's another, it's kind of like photography. It's one of those things that you know you'll never master
能够依靠你，支持你的决定，知道它不会是完美的，知道你将不得不做出弥补，知道你可能不得不在剪辑中修复一些东西以及诸如此类的事情。我只是觉得这又是另一回事，这有点像摄影。这是那种你知道自己永远无法精通的事情，
and I love the idea of having to pursue something that you'll never master. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I love that, I'm in. Dude, we can fucking talk to you forever, honestly. I love you guys, I love this time. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I love that. I'm in. That's cool. Dude, we can fucking talk to you forever, honestly. I love you guys. I just love you, dude. Yeah, yeah.
我喜欢这种去追求一门你永远无法精通的事物的感觉。对，对，对，对。我喜欢这个，我加入。老兄，我们可以他妈的和聊你一辈子，说实话。我爱你们，我喜欢这段时光。对，对，对，对。我喜欢这个。我加入。太酷了。老兄，我们可以他妈的和聊你一辈子，说实话。我爱你们。我就是爱你，老兄。对，对。
Thank you so much for saying yes and doing this with us. Yeah, thank you. It's been a long time coming. Thank you for having me. I'm a master fan. Thank you, Sean. You're one of the all-timers, JB. Fucking love you, miss you, dude.
非常感谢你答应并和我们一起做这个。对，谢谢。这是期待已久的事。谢谢邀请我。我是超级粉丝。谢谢你，肖恩。你是元老级的，JB。他妈的爱你，想你，老兄。
Miss you guys too. Thank you very much for this time, honestly. Thank you, pal. It was nutritious. Have a great rest of the day. Thanks, brother. I miss you guys too. Thank you very much for this time, honestly. Thank you, pal. It was nutritious. Have a great rest of the day. Thanks, brother. We'll talk to you soon. Thank you.
我也想念你们。非常感谢这段时光，说实话。谢谢你，老朋友。很有收获。祝你今天剩下的时间过得愉快。谢谢，兄弟。我也想念你们。非常感谢这段时光，说实话。谢谢你，老朋友.很有收获。祝你今天剩下的时间过得愉快。谢谢，兄弟。我们很快再聊。谢谢。
See you, Josh. Bye, bye, bye. That is, that's a JB. That's a real JB. That's a capital J, capital B. Yeah, if somebody says, hey, show me the best JB you got. I'm wheeling him out.
再见，乔希。拜拜，拜拜。那才是，那真是一个JB。那是一个真正的JB。那是大写的J，大写的JB。对，如果有人说，嘿，把你最好的JB拿出来。我把他推出来。
Sure, sure. And then like they'll say, well, second, third, fourth, what else? Just a backup. We're gonna go lowercase. Yeah, we're gonna go lowercase like a more of a beta JB. Yeah, I was like, hey guys. Hey, there you are. What if somebody said show me a great BJ?
当然，当然。然后他们会说，好吧，第二个，第三个，第四个，还有什么？只是一个备选。我们要用小写的。对，我们要用小写字母，就像更偏向贝塔级别的JB。对，我当时想，嘿，伙计们。嘿，你在这儿呢。如果有人说展示一个伟大的BJ呢？
And you'd say how much time you got? I'd say, Sean, let me look at your browser history. Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Oh God, yeah, super fun. Yeah, I had the pleasure back in the day, day when it was a different time, but it was still super fun hanging with him. And he's just- Yeah, he's one of those guys that's just electric. He is electric. He's really funny and he's really smart and he's interesting and all that stuff.
你会说你还有多少时间？我会说，肖恩，让我看看你的浏览器历史记录。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
He's well read. Like he's just like one of those. But, Bateman, you've kind of known him, right? On and off for years? Yeah, a little bit. We, we shared an agent for a little while and, Oh right. Yeah. But, um, I think you, you know, I'm a lot better. I wish I, I wish I knew him, um, a lot better. I, I can hang on. We have a lot of friends in common, if you know what I mean. And, uh, he's just a fucking is he back here in LA now full-time? Yeah. They, he was here and then they moved to it.
他博览群书。就像他是那种。不过，贝特曼，你其实挺了解他的，对吧？断断续续好多年了？对，有一点。我们，我们有一段时间共用一个经纪人，而且，哦对。对。但是，嗯，我觉得你，你知道，我好多了。我希望我，我希望我能，嗯，更了解他。我，我能合得来。我们有很多共同的朋友，如果你明白我的意思的话。而且，呃，他真是个他妈的，他现在全职回洛杉矶了吗？对。他们，他在这里，然后他们搬到了。
Like he said, they moved to Atlanta for a bit and then they came back and. Oh, by the way, everybody in Atlanta, I love Atlanta. All right? Me too. It's, oh, it'll surprise you at your time. He does too. He was playing it up.
就像他说的，他们搬去亚特兰大呆了一阵子，然后他们回来了。哦，顺便说一句，亚特兰大的所有人，我爱亚特兰大。好吗？我也是。哦，这会让你大吃一惊的。他也一样。他刚才在装腔作势。
He does too. And his wife is from Atlanta, her whole family and his sister-in-law and brother-in-law who's a good friend of mine, Jackson, who we didn't talk about. He was a really good friend of mine, Jackson, who we didn't talk about, who's a really good buddy of mine who lives in Atlanta. Atlanta is a great, great town. You and I both had awesome experiences in that town.
他也一样。他妻子是亚特兰大人，她的全家以及他的小姨子和小舅子，杰克逊，他是我好朋友，我们刚才没聊到他。杰克逊是个很好的朋友，我们刚才没聊到他，他是我在亚特兰大很好的哥们儿。亚特兰大是一个伟大、伟大的小镇。你和我都在那个小镇有过棒极了的经历。
Yeah, I shot a movie there. It was super hot, but it was wonderful. The people are awesome. It's a great town, et cetera. But that old, yeah, that JB is... I like what he said too, when he was like, he was talking about how he likes to, what does he say, like... Cont about how he likes to, what did he say?
对，我在那拍过一部电影。天气超级热，但真的很棒。那里的人太棒了。这是一个伟大的小镇，等等。但那个老，对，那个JB是……我也喜欢他刚才说的，当他在说他喜欢，他怎么说来着……关于他喜欢怎么说，他刚才说什么来着？
Like... Contrast? Yeah, contrast. Contrast. Almost like bifurcate, right? Like what he's... How did you... Why didn't you use the bifurcate?
像……对比？对，对比。对比。几乎就像分叉，对吧？就像他在……你是怎么……你为什么不用“分叉”这个词？
You just had... Oh, you had it. How he likes to... Go back. We're still rolling. We're still rolling? I think that's the... You like the way he likes to what?
你刚才……哦，你刚才想到了。关于他喜欢怎么……回去。我们还在录。我们还在录吗？我想那是……你喜欢他喜欢怎么……
Bye! Bye! Bye! Oh, Sean, great one. Stupid ass, get over here. I can't believe you blew it. Smart. What? Smart. What?
再见！再见！再见！哦，肖恩，太棒了。大笨蛋，过来。真不敢相信你搞砸了。聪明。什么？聪明。什么？
SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
SmartLess是100%有机且由smart手工制作的。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart guys. Hi guys. Oh Darcy's here. Guys, we have a friend with us today. Yes, oh my gosh. It's Darcy Cardin. Darcy.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明的人。大家好。哦，达西来了。伙计们，我们今天迎来了一位朋友。是的，哦天哪。是达西·卡顿。达西。
Hello brothers. Hello sister. Hi. How are you Darcy Cardin? Good to see you guys. Thanks for having me. Darcy, who everybody knows from a million things, like the good place, and you were just on Broadway,
你好，兄弟们。你好，姐妹。嗨。你好吗，达西·卡顿？很高兴见到你们。谢谢邀请我。达西，大家都通过无数部作品认识她，比如《善地》，你刚刚还在百老汇演出，
we're just on Broadway at the same time. With you, my Broadway brother. Yes. At the exact same time. Well Darcy, what we apologize to him is the same time. With you, my Broadway brother. Yes. At the exact same time. Well, Darcy, what we apologize to was you on Broadway. Don't you dare apologize. I was in a, no, don't apologize, I'm telling you not to. It was a limited run.
我们刚刚同时在百老汇演出。和你一起，我的百老汇兄弟。是的。在同一时间。嗯，达西，我们向他道歉的是同一时间。和你一起，我的百老汇兄弟。是的。在同一时间。嗯，达西，我们道歉的是你在百老汇演出。你可千万别道歉。我当时在，不，别道歉，我叫你别道歉。那是一场限定演出。
It was a short one. It was called the Thanksgiving Play. The Thanksgiving Play. And you, and I heard you were fantastic. Did you have to, I'm just having visions of you having to go through a full Thanksgiving meal every performance. Was that what it was? No, that's what I thought it was going to be before I read it to you. And I was like, God, eating on stage, what will that be like?
时间很短。它叫《感恩节戏剧》。《感恩节戏剧》。你，我听说你太棒了。你是不是得，我脑海里浮现出你每场演出都得吃一整顿感恩节大餐的画面。是这样的吗？不，在我读剧本之前，我也以为会是这样。当时我想，天哪，在舞台上吃东西，那会是什么样？
There's no Thanksgiving meal. I love that I go right to the eating. But we did, it was a bloody show. Yeah. Oh no. Which is kind of, which is killing turkeys. I don't want to give anything away, although I did just We were just killing turkeys. I don't wanna give anything away, although I did just say it was a bloody show.
根本没有感恩节大餐。我真喜欢我直接联想到吃东西。但我们演的确实是一部血腥的剧。是的。哦不。也就是杀火鸡。我不想剧透，虽然我刚刚我们刚刚在杀火鸡。我不想剧透，虽然我刚刚确实说了这是一部血腥的剧。
And plus it's not running anymore, but it's a beautiful, wonderful, funny play written by Larissa Fasthorse, the first Native American woman to ever have a play on Broadway. Wow, that's cool. But we were truly covered in blood, head to toe every night,
而且况且它现在已经不演了，但这是一部美丽、精彩、搞笑的剧，由莉萨·法斯霍尔编剧，她是有史以来第一位在百老汇上演戏剧的美洲原住民女性。哇，太酷了。但我们确实每天晚上从头到脚都沾满鲜血，
so we had to like, we'd walk off stage and like get in the shower. Now I'm getting it, now I'm getting it. Not together. Now I'm understanding it. Now I'm getting the, now I'm understanding. Who said that? Storyline. No, nobody did. But Darcy, we're so excited because Smart List Media,
所以我们不得不像，走下舞台然后去冲个澡。现在我懂了，现在我懂了。不是一起。现在我明白了。现在我懂了，现在我明白了。谁说的？剧情。不，没有人。但是达西，我们太兴奋了，因为Smart List Media
it has a new show and it's called Wiki Hole. That's right. No blood in it at all, right? No blood, we haven't had any blood yet. No blood yet. It's bloodless. But Wiki Hole premieres Monday, March 4th, wherever you get your podcasts.
有一档新节目叫《维基深洞》。没错。里面一点血都没有，对吧？没有血，我们目前还没有血。目前还没有。没有血。但《维基深洞》将于3月4日星期一首播，无论你在哪里收听播客都能收听。
So we're super excited. Tell our listeners that don't know as much about it as we do a little about what the WikiHole, what's in store for people in the whole. They need to know. They need to know. It's a super fun trivia show. We have a panel of three guests every time.
所以我们超级兴奋。给那些对它不太了解的听众介绍一下什么是维基深洞，洞里有什么好玩的。他们需要知道。他们需要知道。这是一个超级好玩的冷知识节目。我们每次都有一个由三位嘉宾组成的固定小组。
Different guests each week? Different, super funny, the funniest people you know. You're like the best, best, best, funniest actors and comedians and musicians. Some of my best friends, some of my future best friends. It's all, really, we've had like amazing people on it. And you basically, you have like one subject, one person? We start off with any random subject that you could look up on Wikipedia. Right, one person. We start off with any random subject
每周嘉宾都不同？不同的，超级搞笑，都是你认识的最搞笑的人。就像最棒、最棒、最棒、最搞笑的演员、喜剧演员和音乐家。我的一些最好朋友，我未来的一些最好朋友。真的，我们邀请过非常了不起的人上节目。你基本上，你只有一个主题，一个人？我们从你可以在维基百科上查到的任何随机主题开始。对，一个人。我们从任何随机主题开始
that you could look up on Wikipedia. Right, a donut. A donut, for example. It's like an improv class. Give me one word from the audience. Yes, totally, totally. And from there. You just, whatever you,
你可以在维基百科上查到。对，甜甜圈。比如甜甜圈。这就像即兴表演课。从观众那里给我一个词。是的，完全，完全。从那里开始。你只要，无论你，
if you looked up donut on Wikipedia, you would find yourself clicking on something. Picture of me. Picture of Sean. Picture of Sean. So there's like little, what do they call, hot links inside? spicy hot links inside a wiki page. Delicious.
如果你在维基百科上查甜甜圈，你会发现自己点击了某些东西。我的照片。肖恩的照片。肖恩的照片。所以里面有小小的，他们叫什么来着，热链接？维基页面里面辛辣的热链接。太美味了。
And when you click on those things, it'll take you down another sort of fork in the road and the history of donuts. We may get eventually to a picture of Sean because he's famous for his enjoyment of the donut. Live for Don. And then we'd get into a wiki hole that we'd get into Will and Grace. Yes. And into parental neglect.
当你点击这些东西时，它会把你带到另一个岔路口和甜甜圈的历史。我们最终可能会看到一张肖恩的照片，因为他以喜欢甜甜圈而闻名。为甜甜圈而活。然后我们会进入一个维基深洞，进入《威尔和格蕾丝》。是的。并进入对父母的忽视。
All of those things. Yeah, okay. That's it, that's exactly right, yeah. And then it'll get back into SmartList and then it'll get back into wiki hole and you'll be right back where you started. Will, Will, Will, I don't wanna give anything away. I really don't.
所有这些事情。是的，好吧。就是这样，完全正确，是的。然后它会回到SmartList，然后回到维基深洞，你就会回到你开始的地方。威尔，威尔，威尔，我不想剧透。我真的不想。
And you're our tour guide throughout it. Yeah, I'm always gonna take you through the hole. I've listened to it and anything away. I really don't. And you're our tour guide throughout it. Yeah, I'm always going to take you through the whole. I've listened to it and it's fantastic. Thanks, Sean. I have hysterical. Love it. Thanks. I want to play wiki hole.
你自始至终都是我们的导游。是的，我总是会带你穿过这个深洞。我听过了，不想剧透。我真的不想。你自始至终都是我们的导游。是的，我总是会带你穿过这个深洞。我听过了，而且太棒了。谢谢，肖恩。我笑得前俯后仰。太棒了。谢谢。我想玩维基深洞。
How do we, I want to play. Yeah, I would love to. Will you? Yeah, let's do it. Okay, so if we were to start with the smart list hole, there's so many, I could start with anything. You guys have had these incredible careers. You've worked with everybody. You have won awards.
我们怎么，我想玩。是的，我很乐意。你愿意吗？好吧，如果我们从smart list深洞开始，有太多了，我可以从任何事情开始。你们都有着如此不可思议的职业生涯。你们和所有人都合作过。你们得过奖。
But the thing that I keep coming back to is one man's sandwich, Sean. You have a goddamn tuna fish sandwich for lunch every day, is that right? Almost every day. Okay, almost every day. That is psychotic. I had to find out more.
但我一直念念不忘的是一个男人的三明治，肖恩。你每天午饭都要吃一个该死的金枪鱼三明治，是这样吗？几乎每天。好吧，几乎每天。这太精神病了。我得去了解更多。
So I wick find out more. So I wickied tuna sandwiches. Is he gonna have one today actually? Really? Okay, I might do. And here is our first question, okay? The top of the hole today is gonna be tuna fish sandwich.
所以我就去维基了解更多。所以我就去查了金枪鱼三明治。他今天其实会吃一个吗？真的吗？好吧，我可能会吃。这里是我们的第一个问题，好吗？今天深洞的顶部将是金枪鱼三明治。
Okay, so for the first question, you each have a chance to list the ingredients, okay? And you're gonna get one point per ingredient. Don't freak out, Sean, don't freak out. I see you're freaking out. Well, it just can be, there's so many different ingredients you could put in. I know, okay, but listen, listen.
好的，对于第一个问题，你们每个人都有机会列出配料，好吗？每种配料得一分。别慌，肖恩，别慌。我看到你在慌了。好吧，这可能，你可以放进去的配料太多了。我知道，好吧，但是听着，听着。
There are five ingredients listed to make a tuna fish sandwich at the top of the tuna fish sandwich, wiki page. So the five ingredients, the most common five ingredients. Manes. Okay. Celery. Yeah. Wow, nothing for celery? No, no, no, no, I'm not gonna tell you until you all do it. Mannees. Okay. Celery. Yeah. Wow.
金枪鱼三明治维基页面的顶部列出了制作金枪鱼三明治的五种配料。所以这五种配料，最常见的五种配料。蛋黄酱。好的。西芹。是的。哇，没有西芹吗？不，不，不，不，等你们都说完了我再告诉你们。蛋黄酱。好的。西芹。是的。哇。
Nothing for celery. No, no, no. I'm not going to tell you until you all do it. Oh, okay. Yeah. You each say five. Okay. Mannees and celery.
没有西芹。不，不，不。等你们都说完了我再告诉你们。哦，好吧。是的。你们每个人说五个。好吧。蛋黄酱和西芹。
Mannees and celery. Some people put mustard in it. Some people put capers in it. Okay. And like hard boiled eggs. Okay. Can I go now? Yes, please.
蛋黄酱和西芹。有些人会在里面放芥末。有些人会在里面放刺山柑。好的。还有像水煮蛋。好的。我现在可以说了吗？可以，请说。
Tuna fish. Well, of course. Tuna go now? Yes, please. Tuna fish. Well, fucking idiot. Well, of course you didn't. Yeah, guess what? That's one of them. No, you didn't say it. You didn't say it. Well, that's too bad.
金枪鱼。嗯，当然。金枪鱼现在说？可以，请说。金枪鱼。嗯，他妈的笨蛋。嗯，当然你没说。是的，你猜怎么着？那是其中之一。不，你没说。你没说。好吧，那太遗憾了。
So tuna fish. No, it's not understood. Have you ever played a game before? Well, you're not gonna make a tuna fish sandwich with a chicken? It's like, oh, I've obviously got a touchdown. I'm not gonna go get the touchdown. I've just assumed that I got a touchdown. So tuna fish, mayonnaise, bread. Don't get the touchdown. I obviously just assumed that. Touchdown.
所以金枪鱼。不，这是不言而喻的。你以前玩过游戏吗？好吧，你不会用鸡肉做金枪鱼三明治吧？就像，哦，我显然已经达阵了。我才不去拿达阵呢。我只是假设我已经达阵了。所以金枪鱼，蛋黄酱，面包。别拿达阵。我显然只是假设了。达阵。
So tuna fish, mayonnaise, bread, celery, and pepper. Okay. Will, you ready? Yeah. Okay. Tuna fish. Yeah. I mean, I'm not saying this or no, I'm just saying,
所以金枪鱼，蛋黄酱，面包，西芹和胡椒。好的，威尔，准备好了吗？是的。好的。金枪鱼。是的。我的意思是，我不是说这个或者不，我只是说，
yeah, you said that. Yeah, no, fish. Yeah. I mean, I'm not saying this or no, I'm just saying yeah, you said that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. Bread. Mm-hmm. Mayo. Mm-hmm. Celery.
对，你说了。对，不，鱼。我的意思是，我不是说这个或者不，我只是说对，你说了。对，对，对。好吧。面包。嗯哼。蛋黄酱。嗯哼。西芹。
Slower, Will. No, no, he's thinking. Onion. Green onion. Ew. Okay. It's personal preference and that's only four. What's your fifth? No, I think he said, wait, didn't you say?
慢点，威尔。不，不，他在思考。洋葱。青葱。额。好吧。这是个人喜好，而且这只有四个。你的第五个是什么？不，我记得他说过，等等，你刚才没说吗？
I know it's five. I think he said five. You guys. No, I'm... Guess what? What? Will got all fucking five right. You're joking me.
我知道是五个。我想他说的是五个。你们。不，我……你猜怎么着？什么？威尔他妈的五个全猜对了。你在开玩笑吧。
I'm not kidding. So say it again. Tuna, mayo, celery, onion, bread. So onion is a required element. So I think it's a common, yeah. So hang on, hang on. Sorry, Darcy, I don't wanna cut you off because these guys are about to apologize to me.
我没开玩笑。再念一遍。金枪鱼，蛋黄酱，西芹，洋葱，面包。所以洋葱是必不可少的元素。所以我觉得这是一个常见的，对。等等，等等。对不起，达西，我不想打断你，因为这几个人正准备向我道歉。
Please. For a ritual. Jason's got something in his mouth right now, but I imagine when he finishes chewing that thing, he's gonna apologize for going, the fucking, the fucking, the fucking, the fucking. White onion or white onion or red onion? Well, it just says onion.
请吧。为了一个仪式。杰森现在嘴里嚼着东西，但我猜当他嚼完那个东西后，他会为自己刚才说“他妈的，他妈的，他妈的，他妈的”而道歉。白洋葱还是红洋葱？好吧，上面只写了洋葱。
It doesn't. It just says onion. That's interesting, I gotta try it with onion. Yeah, I bet it'd be delicious. I mean, all your sandwiches sounded delicious, but Will got them all right, Jason got four points and Will, I'm sorry, Jason got four points and Sean got two points.
没有。上面只写了洋葱。这挺有意思的，我得用洋葱试试。是的，我打赌一定很好吃。我的意思是，你们所有的三明治听起来都很好吃，但威尔全猜对了，杰森得了四分，威尔，对不起，杰森得了四分，肖恩得了两分。
Yeah, Sean, you lose. Great, great, we have more. It's anybody's game. Four points and will sorry Jason got four points and Shawn got two points. Yeah It's anybody's game, right? So what's the spicy hot link we go to offer you know what you are a donut? Do you put in yours? Tuna. Uh-huh. Don't say tuna like that. Of course you have to put fucking tuna. Celery and tons of mayo. Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
对，肖恩，你输了。太棒了，太棒了，我们还有。胜负未分。四分，威尔，对不起，杰森得了四分，肖恩得了两分。对，胜负未分，对吧？那么我们要去的下一个辛辣热链接是什么，你知道吗，你是个甜甜圈？你会在你的里面放什么？金枪鱼。嗯哼。别那样说金枪鱼。你当然得放他妈的金枪鱼。西芹和大量的蛋黄酱。姆，姆，姆，姆，姆。
Okay, great, delicious. Dorsey, wait, if you think I'm playing again after I fucking smoke these guys. No, we're not done. We're not done. You've just entered the hole. You've just started. You have to travel down into the hole now
好的，太棒了，美味。达西，等等，如果你以为我在把这群混蛋干掉之后还会再玩一次的话。不，我们还没结束。我们还没结束。你才刚进入深洞。你才刚开始。你现在必须深入洞穴
We have to scale down this gigantic hole and this is even a small hole for you guys, but usually it's a really big hole Click click a spicy link Credit I want to get some credit for the restraint you're getting exercising Incredible, okay, so here's our next question. You will each have a chance to answer this. The closest without going over wins. What percentage of canned tuna in the US is used for tuna sandwiches? Okay, I'm a first, I'm first. And I will say, what percentage of canned tuna
我们必须顺着这个巨大的洞爬下去，对你们来说这甚至是一个小洞，但通常这是一个非常大的洞，点击，点击辛辣链接。信用，我想为你们表现出的克制获得一些信用。不可思议，好的，这是我们的下一个问题。你们每个人都有机会回答。最接近而不超过者获胜。美国罐装金枪鱼中用于制作金枪鱼三明治的比例是多少？好的，我是第一个，我是第一个。我会说，罐装金枪鱼
is used for tuna fish sandwich? I would say 90. Okay. Okay, that's my guess. Great. Well, cause he said 90, I'll say 90. Okay. Okay, that's my guess. Great. Well, cause he said 90, I'll say 95. Okay. Dumb.
用于金枪鱼三明治的比例是多少？我会说90%。好的。好的，这是我的猜测。太棒了。好吧，既然他说了90%，那我就说95%。好的。笨蛋。
Should've said 91. Dumb. I'm gonna say 40. Okay, okay. 40. Now, I was shocked by this, but the answer is 52%. So will you fucking got it again?
应该说91的。笨蛋。我要说40%。好的，好的。40%。现在，我对此感到震惊，但答案是52%。所以威尔你他妈的又猜对了。
Wow. Jesus. Why is that? Cause I bet you some of tuna that's canned is also used for animals, for cats and dogs and shit like that. I didn't even think of that. I was, all I could think of was casserole. Yeah.
哇。天哪。为什么会这样？我敢打赌，有些罐装金枪鱼也被用来喂动物，比如猫和狗之类的。我根本没想到这一点。我当时能想到的只有砂锅菜。是的。
It's a fucking, by the way, you don't want to keep playing this game with me with these guys. No, no, no, I bet we do. Let's have third one. You're gonna fucking, you're gonna burst into flames. Let's have third one. You're gonna fucking burst into flames. Let's go. What's the next hot line? Okay, here we go.
顺便说一句，你不想和我和这几个人继续玩这个游戏了。不，不，不，我敢打赌我们想。来第三个。你会他妈的，你会气得原地爆炸。来第三个。你会他妈的，你会气得原地爆炸。我们上。下一个热链接是什么？好的，我们开始。
Okay. Look how mad he is. We're, okay. Here we go. Americans consume one third of the total amount of canned tuna sold worldwide every year. And yet, the tuna sandwich is not in the top three most popular sandwiches in the U.S. You'll each have a chance to guess three. What are the most popular sandwiches in the US. You'll each have a chance to guess three. What are the most popular sandwiches,
好的。看他气成什么样了。我们，好的。我们开始。美国人每年消耗全球售出的罐装金枪鱼总量的三分之一。然而，金枪鱼三明治并没有进入美国最受欢迎三明治的前三名。你们每个人都有机会猜三个。美国最受欢迎的三明治是什么？你们每个人都有机会猜三个，美国最受欢迎的三明治，
the three most popular sandwiches in the US, one point per correct? Go ahead, Sean. Go ahead, Sean. Peanut butter and jelly. Sean, you should win this. Yeah, let's just eat it. Peanut butter and jelly.
美国最三个最受欢迎的三明治，猜对一个得一分？说吧，肖恩。说吧，肖恩。花生酱果酱三明治。肖恩，你该赢这个的。对，我们把它吃了。花生酱果酱三明治。
Okay. Like a turkey, like a regular turkey family. No, you can't generalize, be specific. Like, you know, something with turkey. No. Commit. I would have got a touchdown. What are we doing?
好的。像火鸡，就像普通的火鸡三明治。不，你不能概括，要具体。就像，你知道的，某种火鸡。不。坚定点。我本来可以达阵的。我们在干什么？
Why are you on the answer? To walk all the way down there and cross that line. Just say touchdown. Okay, peanut butter, jelly, turkey. Turkey and what's another popular sandwich? You're asking? And roast beef, I don't know. Okay.
为什么你在回答上？一直走到那并越过那条线。直接说达阵。好的，花生酱，果酱，火鸡。火鸡，还有什么受欢迎的三明治？你问我呢？还有烤牛肉，我不知道。好的。
That's the question. Okay. I would say a hamburger. Okay, that's the question. Okay. I would say a hamburger. Okay. It's not a sandwich. I would say a grilled cheese. Oh, grilled cheese. And then I would say a club.
这就是问题所在。好的。我会说汉堡。好的，这就是问题所在。好的。我会说汉堡。好的。这不是三明治。我会说烤奶酪。哦，烤奶酪。然后我会说俱乐部三明治。
Okay, okay. Three more popular sandwiches in the US. That's right. Here he comes. I would say ham, some kind of ham, ham and cheese. Well, which is it, ham or ham and cheese? Yeah, let's come in. Ham and cheese.
好的，好的。美国另外三个最受欢迎的三明治。没错。他来了。我会说火腿，某种火腿，火腿奶酪。好吧，到底是哪个，火腿还是火腿奶酪？是的，我们来吧。火腿奶酪。
Ham and cheese. I'll say ham and cheese. I will say peanut butter and jelly. And I will say egg salad. Okay, wow. This is a tough one, you guys. If you, I would have guessed peanut butter and jelly would have been top number one.
火腿奶酪。我会说火腿奶酪。我会说花生酱果酱三明治。我会说鸡蛋沙拉。好的，哇。这真是一个难题，伙计们。如果你，我本来以为花生酱果酱三明治会是第一名。
It doesn't even crack the top three. Wow. That's why I didn't guess it. Okay, good. Well, Jason, you got one, which is, I know, which is grilled cheese. Grilled cheese, grilled chicken sandwich, surprising, and turkey sandwich. So Sean, you got one as well.
它甚至没能挤进前三。哇。这就是为什么我没猜它。好的，很好。好吧，杰森，你答对了一个，也就是，我知道，也就是烤奶酪。烤奶酪，烤鸡三明治，令人惊讶，还有火鸡三明治。所以肖恩，你也答对了一个。
Okay. No burger, no PB and J. I wonder if they're not qualifying burger as a sandwich. So Sean, you got one as well. Okay. No burger, no PB&J. I wonder if they're not qualifying burger as a sandwich. I wonder the same. That's a big debate. Yeah, it is a big debate. They're not. I mean, this isn't the 1940s we go, I'll have a hamburger sandwich.
好的。没有汉堡，没有PB and J。我想他们可能没有把汉堡归类为三明治。所以肖恩，你也答对了一个。好的。没有汉堡，没有PB&J。我想他们可能没有把汉堡归类为三明治。我也这么想。这是一个巨大的争论。是的，这确实是一个巨大的争论。他们没有。我的意思是，这不是20世纪40年代，我们会说，我要一份汉堡三明治。
I'll just have a hamburger sandwich and a cup of coffee. Yeah, exactly. I don't like that. Put me through to Murray Hill 234. Yeah, exactly. I don't like that. And keep your sales receipt. Okay, let's jump on down the whole to sandwiches. Let's keep going with this.
我只要一份汉堡三明治和一杯咖啡。是的，exactly。我不喜欢这样。帮我接美利山234。是的，exactly。我不喜欢这样。留着你的销售收据。好的，让我们继续深入探讨三明治这个深洞。我们继续这个话题。
Wikipedia has a list devoted to American sandwiches. The only sandwich whose ingredients are a mystery on this list is the Diablo sandwich. Diablo sandwich. So here we go. You'll each have a chance to answer this multiple choice question. In what hit 1970s movie does someone order a Diablo sandwich a
维基百科有一个专门收录美国三明治的列表。这个列表中唯一一个配料成谜的三明治是恶魔三明治。恶魔三明治。所以我们开始。你们每个人都有机会回答这个多选题。在20世纪70年代的哪部热门电影中，有人点了一个恶魔三明治？
Love story be the Poseidon event adventure or see smoky and the bandit Well, I say smoky in the bandit. Okay Poseidon adventure. Okay, just guessing the deal I was gonna say five easy pieces because there was that great scene where Jack Nicholson does the sandwich a bit, huh? Oh yeah. I'm going to say love story just so we each take one. I like that move. Sean, you got it.
A 《爱情故事》，B 《海神号历险记》，还是C 《暂告安全》？好吧，我选《暂告安全》。好的。《海神号历险记》。好的，我只是随便猜的恶魔我本来想说《五部轻松的小品》，因为里面有个很棒的场景，杰克逊·尼克尔森做三明治的一段，哈？哦，对。我要说《爱情故事》，这样我们一人选一个。我喜欢这个举动。肖恩，你答对了。
It's mostly in the band. Oh my God. If Willard won that one, we would never hear the end of it. He'd be the king hole. That's what we're playing for, to be the king hole. Hole king. Hole king. What was your handle in king whole. Whole king. Whole king. What was your handle in high school?
是《暂告安全》。哦，天哪。如果威尔赢了那个，我们永远都听不到他显摆了。他会成为深洞之王。这就是我们在争夺的，成为深洞之王。深洞之王。深洞之王。你在高中的绰号是什么？
Whole king. Whole king. Whole king. Whole king. So Sheriff Justice, played by Jackie Gleason, orders a diablo sandwich. Yeah, it's a very funny scene I watched the last time. When I get home, I'm gonna hit your mama right in the mouth. That was it.
整个国王。整个国王。整个国王。整个国王。所以杰基·格里森饰演的治安官贾斯蒂斯点了一份魔鬼三明治。是的，这是我上次看的一个非常搞笑的场景。等我回到家，我要狠狠扇你妈妈的嘴巴。就是这样。
You know what he says? Something like that. There's no way you could come from my loins. Good. So who won Darcy? Okay, my little mouse will tell me the score in five seconds and I'll get a little. You guys, Will is the winner with six points.
你知道他说什么吗？差不多就是这样。你绝不可能是我骨肉。很好。那么谁赢了，达西？好的，我的小老鼠会在五秒钟内告诉我分数，我会得到一点……伙计们，威尔以六分获胜。
Wow. Jason and Sean, you both had five. You were so goddamn close. Wow. But what does one get when they win or lose on the wiki hole? You're gonna love this. You get a generous donation made in your name to Wikipedia.
哇。杰森和肖恩，你们俩都是五分。你们太该死地接近了。哇。但是当人们在维基洞赢得或输掉比赛时会得到什么？你会喜欢这个的。你会以你的名义向维基百科进行慷慨捐赠。
I like that. Oh, that's good. They're always looking. Which is great, right? Because they're always looking. Yeah, we need that. And you're never actually saying yes. You're always kind of Xing it up.
我喜欢这样。哦，那太好了。他们一直在寻找。这太棒了，对吧？因为他们一直在寻找。是的，我们需要这个。而且你从来没有真正说“好”。你总是有点在打哈哈。
And now I can feel less guilty for just clicking through. Exactly. Yeah, that's exactly right. Very good. Okay, guys, I have one more question for you. Yeah. What is Henry Winkler's favorite sandwich? The hoagie?
现在我可以少一点只顾点过去的负罪感了。没错。是的，完全正确。非常棒。好吧，伙计们，我还有一个问题要问你们。是的。亨利·温克勒最喜欢的三明治是什么？荷奇三明治？
I want to say a shark sandwich. That's what I want to say, but it's still... I'm gonna say, you mean the jumping the shark sandwich? Yeah, you know. I would say the hollowed out bagel. Mm, you think he'd hollow out a bagel? No, I don't want to put my finger in it. I've had it at his house with him before.
我想说鲨鱼三明治。这就是我想说的，但它还是……我要说，你是说“跃过鲨鱼”三明治吗？是的，你知道的。我会说挖空的百吉饼。嗯，你觉得他会挖空百吉饼吗？不，我不想把我的手指伸进去。我和他在他家一起吃过。
Yeah, okay. Well, to get the answer, we have a very special message from a very special guest. Hi, Jason Willen, Sean. It's Henry Winkler with the answer to my favorite sandwich. There are two parts. The first is a tuna sandwich with mayo, ketchup,
是的，好吧。为了得到答案，我们有一位非常特殊的嘉宾带来了一条非常特别的信息。嗨，杰森、威尔、肖恩。我是亨利·温克勒，带着我最喜欢的三明治的答案。有两个部分。第一部分是金枪鱼三明治，配蛋黄酱、番茄酱、
and finely diced onions on Wonder Bread. Part two is the day after Thanksgiving sandwich, Wonder Bread again, see the bridge. Mayo, turkey, fried stuffing, cranberry sauce out of the can, none of that berry crap. And then Wonder Bread. Hey, Dars, what is it like actually being a guest on the show and then, you know, instead of just being a question, you know, I had two of them at my dining room table and the tall one, you know, that third guy,
还有切得极细的洋葱，夹在奇迹面包里。第二部分是感恩节后一天的三明治，依然是奇迹面包，注意连接。蛋黄酱、火鸡、炸填料、罐装蔓越莓酱（不要那种浆果垃圾），然后又是奇迹面包。嘿，达尔斯，作为节目的嘉宾是什么感觉，然后，你知道，而不是仅仅作为一个问题，你知道，我餐桌上有两个，那个高的，你知道，第三个家伙，
I helped him get his Tony. You know what, Dars, You're in a new podcast, Wiki-Hole, and I could bring one or both sandwiches if I were a guest on that podcast. There you go. What a sweet podcast. How great is that? We love it. We love it. I mean, if I could put him in a sandwich, I'd snack on him all day, every day.
我帮他得到了他的托尼奖。你知道吗，达尔斯，你在一个新播客“Wiki-Hole”里，如果我是那个播客的嘉宾，我可以带一个或两个三明治去。给你。多么甜蜜的播客。那有多棒？我们喜欢。我们喜欢。我的意思是，如果我能把他夹进三明治里，我天天都会吃他。
Oh, delicious. He's the nicest man in show business. Oh, yeah. I've got an issue with his Wonder Bread addiction though, darn it. I want him around for hundreds of years. I know, I know. What is it that? But it is delicious. It is delicious.
哦，太美味了。他是演艺界最好的人。哦，是的。不过，我对他对奇迹面包的痴迷有点意见，该死。我希望他在世上活几百年。我知道，我知道。这是什么？但它确实美味。它确实美味。
Okay, quickly. I'm going to retrace the whole. We started with tuna fish sandwich, which led us to American sandwiches, which then led us to Smoky and the Bandit, which led us to Henry Wink the Bandit, which led us to Henry Winkler and right back to tuna fish sandwiches. I mean, how about one of his sandwiches with tuna fish sandwiches? I love that. I know. He's a smart guy. The full episodes go, we go a little bit deeper into these wiki holes.
好吧，快点。我要回顾一下整个过程。我们从金枪鱼三明治开始，这把我们引向了美国三明治，然后把我们引向了《横冲直撞》，这把我们引向了亨利·温克，然后又回到了金枪鱼三明治。我的意思是，用他的三明治配金枪鱼三明治怎么样？我喜欢这样。我知道。他是个聪明人。完整剧集会更深入地探讨这些维基洞穴。
It's super fun. You're gonna love it. Play along with us. We can't wait and and my three brothers, I'd love to have you on the full whole. We would love it. See you at the whole. See you at the whole. See you at the whole. So many times I've gotten that. Now listen, this is information we need to know.
超级好玩。你会喜欢的。和我们一起玩。我们等不及了，还有我的三个兄弟，我很乐意邀请你们参加完整的节目。我们会很乐意的。在洞里见。在洞里见。在洞里见。我有过这么多次这样的经历。现在听着，这是我们需要知道的信息。
It premieres Monday, March 4th, wherever you get your new podcast and new episodes are released every week. Or you can hear it a week early on Amazon Music or the Wondery app starting Monday, February 26th. Monday, February 26th, you say. Monday, February 26th, is that what you said? Monday, February 26th, you say. Oh, the 26th of February is when WikiHole is gonna start.
它将于 3 月 4 日星期一首播，无论你在哪里收听新播客，新剧集每周发布一次。或者你可以从 2 月 26 日星期一开始，在 Amazon Music 或 Wondery 应用程序上提前一周收听。你说是 2 月 26 日星期一。2 月 26 日星期一，你是这么说的吗？你说是 2 月 26 日星期一。哦，2 月 26 日是 WikiHole 开始的日子。
WikiHole with Darcy Cardin. Is at the end of February, specifically on the 26th, I think, is the early week on Amazon Wondery. And for everybody on March 4th. I love that, yeah. Free wherever you get your podcasts. March 4th wide. To RC, we love you.
由达西·卡丹主持的 WikiHole。在二月底，具体是在 26 号，我想，是在 Amazon Wondery 上的提前周。大家可以在 3 月 4 日收听。我喜欢这样，是的。免费的，无论你在哪里收听播客。3 月 4 日全面上线。RC，我们爱你。
We can't wait for the new show. Thank you for being part of the family and smartless media. You guys, I love you so much. Thank you for doing this. Thank you so much for having me. This is so fun. Bye guys. Bye.
我们迫不及待地想看新节目。感谢您成为这个大家庭和 smartless media 的一员。伙计们，我太爱你们了。谢谢你们做这些。非常感谢邀请我。太有趣了。再见，伙计们。再见。
Bye. If you like smartless, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen add free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com. shirts, played by HBO's industries, Myhalla Harald, a brilliant scholarship student who has to quickly adapt to her newfound eat or be eaten world. Ava's ambitions take hold and her small town values break in hopes of becoming the first scholarship
再见。如果你喜欢 smartless，你可以通过在 Wondery 应用程序或 Apple Podcasts 上加入 Wondery Plus，现在就免费且无广告地收听。Prime 会员可以在 Amazon Music 上免费无广告收听。在你离开之前，请在 Wondery.com 上填写一份简短的调查，告诉我们关于你的信息。由 HBO 的《产业》主演的...，米哈拉·哈罗德是一名聪明的奖学金学生，她必须迅速适应她新发现的弱肉强食的世界。艾娃的野心占据了上风，她的小镇价值观被打破，希望能成为第一位获得奖学金的...的
student to make the list. Bishop Gray is all coveted academic top ten, curated by the headmaster himself. But after realizing she has no chance at the list on her own, she reluctantly accepts an invitation to a secret underground society that pulls the strings on campus life and academic success. If she bends to their will, she'll have everything she's ever dreamed of. But at what cost? Academy takes you into the world of a cutthroat private school where power, money, and sex collide in a game of life and death. Follow Academy on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts.
学生，进入这份名单。主教格雷是所有令人垂涎的学术前十名，由校长亲自挑选。但在意识到自己靠自己没有机会进入名单后，她勉强接受了一个秘密地下社团的邀请，该社团操纵着校园生活和学业成功。如果她屈服于他们的意愿，她将拥有一切梦寐以求的东西。但代价是什么？《学院》带你进入一个残酷的私立学校世界，在这里权力和金钱、性在一个生死游戏中交织在一起。在 Wondery 应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方关注《学院》。
You can binge all episodes of Academy early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以通过加入 Wondery Plus 立即畅听《学院》的所有剧集，且无需广告。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。